These are just like quick ads we
do very informal. Hey everybody,
this episode of the Joe Rogan
experience has brought [inaudible]
said my name should say the podcast they
experience brought to you by stamps.com
with stamps.com is a method that
allows you to use us postal service,
um, to print us postal service
right from your home computer,
right from your office computer,
right from your desktop,
just a regular old computer
and a regular old printer.
You can print official us postage
for any letter, any package,
any class of mail,
all for a fraction of the cost
of an expensive Posto meter.
And if you go to stamps.com you never
have to go to the post office again.
It's so easy with this
deal that we offer you.
If you click on the old school microphone
in the upper right hand corner of
stamps.com you enter in the Promo
Code j r e you get a no risk trial,
$110 bonus offer,
which includes a free digital scale
and up to $55 of free postage.
Then you take your packages, you weigh
them, you calculate all the jazz printout,
official US postage,
slap it on the old box post man comes,
hand it to him and your dignity,
dignity, done. That's it.
You don't have to go to the post office.
You don't have to wait in line.
You don't have to talk to some completely
under motivated and underwhelmed
person who really doesn't
want to be there at all.
Much rather beat you over
the head with a club.
Then weigh your stupid fucking packages.
You don't have to do any of that.
All you have to do is go to stamps.com
and sign up for this offer and before you
do anything else, click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage.
Type in j r e that
stamps.com and enter in j r.
E it's easy,
it's convenient and you remove
stress and hassle from your life.
If you own a small business or if you
regularly send out packages of varying
weights and sizes.
This is the way to co kid tourist me
stamps.com and remember before you do
anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in j r e for your
$110 bonus offer.
We'll also,
we're also brought to you by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a fantastic
way to deal with St Lo.
I like stamps.com you can deal with
shit from your home that you would
ordinarily have to go somewhere for them.
With legal zoom,
you could deal with so many legal
issues without having to schedule an
appointment with a lawyer on their time.
Drive through traffic park,
sit down, paying an exorbitant amount
of money to some person. Again,
who doesn't really want to fucking
talk to you, they just want your cash.
You could do all that stuff at home and
do it for a fraction of the cost and do
it quite easily. You can form an LLC
or incorporate start your own business.
Very easy to do. You can apply for
a patent to secure an invention,
register your trademark to protect your
products and services and you could do
it all drunk and naked.
No one can stop you.
You can take illegal drugs
and do something legal.
Do you know that? I'm not,
I'm not advising it,
but if you so chose to do it,
it is your right as a person,
as long as you do everything correctly
and everything's filled out the way it's
supposed to be,
you're good.
And if it's not filled out
the way it's supposed to be,
here's the beauty of legal zoom.
Legal Zoom can connect you to a
third party independent attorney.
If you're in a cold sweat panic and you
think that you've done something illegal.
If you filled out the forms and you're
like, this shit is not gonna fly,
you can contact legal zoom and they
will hook you up with a third party
attorney.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they do provide you with legal self
help through independent attorneys.
See legal self help is the way to do it.
If you can get things done like
filing patents, like for me,
LLCs forming a will,
you can even get divorced.
You can get divorced through legal zoom
and they have an a plus rating from the
better business bureau. You can't go
wrong with that. A plus, not a minus,
not B plus a plus from the better
business bureau over the past 14 years.
They've helped over a million
businesses get started, right?
Go to legal zoom.com and
when you go through the month
of June and you can get a
special price on trademark,
copyright or provisional patent
applications by using the referral code,
Rogan at checkout,
celebrate innovation with legal
zoom through the end of June.
I remember legal zoom is not a la farm,
but they do provide you with legal
help through independent attorneys.
Someone's trying to fucking text me
in the middle of a God damn podcast.
I guess they don't listen anyway,
go to legal zoom.com use the
code word Rogan at checkout.
You hear that weird noise.
You hear that?
You don't hear that?
I think it's the phone. I think if I
put my phone near my computer, they'd,
they'd fucking argue with each other.
And telepathically it's probably
what it is. Um, that's it. Legal,
zoom.com use a codeword Rogan.
We're also brought to you by ting.
Ting is a mobile service
that does things differently,
did do things on their own terms.
And what that means is they buy
time through the sprint backbone.
They use sprints. So you get the exact
same service that you get with sprint,
but you get it with no contracts,
no early termination fees,
no nonsense.
They don't trick you.
And there's a lot of ways that
cell phone companies make money.
And one of the ways
they make money is they,
they charge you for x amount per month.
Like, you know, you have a deal where you,
you know, you get 1200 minutes a
month or whatever the hell it is.
But when you do that, most of the
time you're not using those minutes,
but you're still paying for those minutes.
The weighting does it.
It's a very smart and I,
and I think it's a better way and I think
it's the only way that they're going
to do it in the future. What what
they do is you pay for what you use.
If you use a lot, you pay
more. If you use very little,
you pay less and 98% of people
would save money using tank.
That's a pretty incredible statistic.
If you go to Tim's website,
go to [inaudible] dot com they'll explain
the whole thing to $21 is the average
monthly bill per device for tin customers.
That's amazing because you'd be,
you'd be surprised at how little when you,
when you look at the service minutes,
you know, you know like a hundred
minutes a month, 200 minutes a month.
Most of the time people are texting each
other's days and if you call me a lot,
man, most of the time I
don't pick up the phone.
I don't spend a lot of
time calling people.
$440 is the average annual savings per
device for a business with one to 20
employees. So if you have a
business, Tang is the way to go.
If you want to set up business phones
and you have many options as far as the
phones themselves,
you have all of the best android phones
that are available today and you buy
them. You don't see the thing about when
you go to one of the big name cell phone
companies and you get a phone,
you're not actually buying the phone.
Like if you pay $200 for a phone, you're
not really paying $200 for that phone.
The phone costs probably five or 600
bucks and you think you're paying $200 but
the other 300 to $400 you're paying
off over the course of your contract.
That's why if you try to leave,
they say stick it to you and they make
you pay what you owe them and so it's,
that's what a contract termination fee is.
What's all about is you
still owe money on a device.
You essentially leased a device.
Tink doesn't handle it that way at all.
With Ting. Everything that you, you,
you purchase, what did they sell at?
[inaudible] dot com rogan.ting.com here
are the finest cell phones available
today. Like the, excuse me,
Samsung Galaxy s five,
which is water resistant.
Just added water resistant. If you're
a fucking dork like me, you spell shit.
That's the way to go. They
have a, the HTC one m eight,
all of the best new android phones,
the Samsung Galaxy note three,
which I use fantastic phone. You
can draw on it. It has a pen.
How could you go wrong? And if you
like one of those old crazy grandmas,
they have flip phones, they
have everything. And uh,
as cheap as 42 bucks,
you can get a phone for 42 bucks,
which is kind of ridiculous
in this day and age.
And when you buy it for 42 bucks,
you actually buy it for 42 bucks.
And if you know, you know, you try for
a while and he'd go, you know what,
I want to cancel. Just canceled. That's
it. You don't have to worry about shit.
It's a beautiful ethical
way to do business. And the
results have been fantastic.
Massive, massive public, um,
positive feedback that I've received from
all the people that have switched over
to tank saved money,
loved the company,
loved the idea behind the company and
love the fact that they have a wide
selection of devices.
So go to rogan.ting.com today
and save yourself some cash kids.
All right,
my friend Steve Hilton is here.
We're going to talk about all kinds
of groovy shit. Let's cue the music
experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast,
Steve Hilton, my friend
politics are dirty business,
very dirty.
But just before we get into that show you,
I just want to say you've already
really offended me. Fantastic.
Just want to show you my phone.
Oh, what have you got here?
It is a flip phone. So in your
words, an old crazy grandma.
Well, I have many friends
that carry old flip phones,
but I'm glad that you're actually
just carrying a phone. Exactly.
This is a very new development for
me. Well, it's a good move. So good.
Everyone's been telling you,
I've got to have a phone.
I had not had a phone for many years.
Finally I buckled under the pressure
and I got one of these Steve.
Um, we became friends in Hawaii or
friends or family and we're all friends.
It's a, it's a very cool little,
uh, development. I really enjoy it.
But I think it, I think it's
quite hilarious that, uh,
your wife is involved in Google
and you avoid phones at all costs.
You avoid technology. You feel that
it's too entrenched in our life.
This sort of a digital web that
we've all been connected to. Yeah.
I'm trying to fight it,
Joe. It's tough though.
That's the beautiful thing. When you
don't want to use them, you shut them off.
Yeah.
But that,
that kind of nagging away knowing that's
discipline meditates probably, right.
Well, I feel that there's benefits and
there's certainly negatives to phones,
but I think the positive
aspects outweigh the negative.
I like being able to communicate with
friends and family and loved ones and sent
texts. And I, I, I find it
incredibly addictive though.
And I think it becomes,
I was out at dinner the other day with
a bunch of friends and everyone was on
the ground, damn phone.
There was five of us,
and I was like sitting around
a table looking at everybody,
texting and tweeting and taking photos.
I'm like, we're not even here right now.
I'm like, you guys are, you're
connected to this digital world.
You're talking about how awesome it is
to be here, but you're not even here.
You barely paying attention as new sort
of etiquette developing about, you know,
how to handle this when there's, I think
I was reading something about, well,
you've got eight people around a table
having dinner and it's okay for three of
them to be looking at their devices.
That's okay.
But if it gets to more than three,
someone's got to look up
because that's the rule.
Who says says who establish what?
I don't get it. It's just there.
It's just like anything else.
I mean,
if you're at a bar with some friends and
one guy's just watching TV only and not
engaging in a conversation, that's just
as rude. Yeah, I think that's right.
I find it fascinating. Um, how
my children react to devices.
That's where I really get a sense of
it because they don't have a cultural
context.
You know,
when my four year old watches television
or watches devices and I'll stand front
of her while she's watching
TV and she just reaches
up and tries to move me,
like she doesn't give a
fuck what I'm thinking.
She's just trying to watch this program.
Yeah. You literally can't get in between.
And that point it's like I've really
noticed that if you just, you know,
they're watching something,
that's it. You know, you may,
you may have been away for a week
and you haven't seen them and they're
desperate to see, but if there's something
on TV at that point, no interested.
Yeah. It trumps everything. It trumps
all human interaction and it's,
it's very weird how it does it.
It does it in this strange hypnotic way.
There's nothing else on earth that
gets a four year old to just sit there
motionless, right. And engage. But it
literally stimulates parts of the brand.
There's a lot of quite interesting brain
science about what's going on when,
when kids watch TV and
it's generally fine,
but when it gets to a point where they're
watching you no more than two or three
hours a day, and a lot of kids
these days are in that situation,
it literally starts rewiring their
brain. Yeah. It's not healthy to,
to completely entrench yourself in that
world and to be in that world all day,
every day. But a lot of people
do because it's possible.
But I think that's just
like everything else.
It's like I liked the option to
be able to buy a cheeseburger.
I don't think you should eat
cheeseburgers every day, all day,
but I like it if I want one from driving
by in and out, and I'm like, let's do it.
You know, it's, it's not the best
food for you, but I like the option.
I totally agree with that. I liked
that for television. I liked,
I liked watching swamp people
watch that fuck for naught,
terrible show about a bunch of people,
alligator hunting. And it's, it's,
it's the most predictable show of all
time because they're look for alligators
and occasionally they get alligators,
but there's nothing unusual happens.
They don't run into a giraffe like what
the fuck it was a draft in the swamp. No,
it's just alligators.
And these people were these strange
southern accents in boats and they have
fishing line.
They catch the alligator with fishing
line that sometimes they shoot the
alligators, but it's just
alligator hunters. But they
call it swamp people. Yeah.
I haven't seen that. I'm not sure
that's going to be top of my list.
You should invest, you should
invest your time, you know, doing,
doing a little bit of
everything. I remember when, um,
do you remember that movie came out at
that Mcdonald's supersize me and this guy
got ill and fun. Is Morgan Spurlock?
Yes. Um, you know, he made it,
he made a good point.
But my favorite response to that
was from Mcdonald's when the,
the guy who runs Mcdonald's
in Australia went on,
they took commercials and they went on
air when there's this big PR storm about
the terrible Mcdonald's food and
all this kind of stuff and he,
he went on air with these commercials
and I'm going to now attempt very badly
and Australian accent.
Okay. Then most people hate,
probably couldn't tell the
difference between the British
and Australian. Anyway,
talking about the same. I know,
I get it, I get it. And he said,
um, apparently there's some
bloke he's going around saying,
if you eat too much of our food and don't
take any exercise, you get fat. Well,
I could've told you that. I just got
really sweet response, which is, yeah,
we'll have something that's not good,
but a little bit's okay.
That's a quite Australian
response to as opposed to the measured
American legalees that you'd probably
hear from [inaudible]. Good. Yeah. Yeah.
You know I have a real issue
with that documentary and with,
he did a show also called 30 days
because I know what they're doing there.
They're not necessarily
just investigating, right?
They're also trying to achieve a desired
result and that desired result being
something bad.
They're,
they're trying to do
something that's going to be
titillating and oh my goodness,
his liver is going bad. Like he's,
he's sick, he's sick, he's toxic.
There's a lot of people that
have called bullshit on that,
especially the liver toxins and all
that stuff. They're like, where's this?
Where's the liver toxin?
You're dealing with carbohydrates and
proteins and you know, and, and fats,
but it's not like this. These things
aren't toxic. They're just not good.
They're just high in cholesterol and
they're kind of fatty and sugary. Yup.
But I know for a fact that they
did some fuckery on his show.
He had a show called 30 days where
he's trying to achieve the same results
because they went to a friend
of mine who's a doctor and he,
this doctor specializes in hormone
replacement therapy for older people,
for older people and people that are,
you know like you start getting older,
you want to replace your testosterone
and things along those lines and they
wanted to do it in 30 days and they
wanted to do it on this program.
Take a man who's getting older and in
30 days injected with hormones and the
doctor who's an ethical doctor said,
you don't ever do that. He said,
we'd never do that.
And he said,
well we would do is we would get you on
a proper diet. I would take your blood,
it would take a week to get
your blood results back.
I get your blood results back.
I'd want to get a detailed analysis of
what you're eating, what you're doing,
what kind of a lifestyle do you have.
It's not a simple fix
like we give you hormones.
So what they did is they found a quack
doctor who did just shoot the guy up with
hormones and the guy was like,
oh,
roid rage and angry afterwards and his
fucking was wife wanted to keep him
chubby. I mean the whole thing
was a disaster. It was like,
this is not an ethical examination
of this. It makes it real.
It's, it's like it's entertainment.
It's not a documentary or something.
It's deceiving though. The problem with
entertainment is it's not a puppet show.
Okay. It's not a cartoon. You're,
you're pretending that
you're exploring these ideas.
And when I was doing that Scifi show,
I found some similar issues with certain
producers and certain people who were
used to that world of reality TV
reality TV has become this very strange
mishmash of choreographed choreograph
scenarios and predetermined scenarios,
predetermined results.
And they do it sort of in
this guise of reality TV.
But it's sir, it's essentially, it's
like loosely scripted bullshit. Yeah.
And they're pretending that it's like,
this is what's going on in the
doctor's office. No, you set that up.
That's not what goes on
at a doctor's office.
It's not what would go
on at a doctor's office.
You're pretending because that's
going to get people to freak out.
They took the an agenda,
you know, they're trying to make
a point and they set up like that.
They edit it like that. It's, you
know, it's totally right. Well,
the whole business is completely fucked
because the business has started off
with a bunch of people that
came over from scripted shows.
So the legacy people that were involved
in these dramatic shows where there were
no, until survivor came along,
there were no reality shows,
quote unquote reality shows.
So I go,
I have a deep understanding of this
because I hosted fear factor for six years
and because fear factor came in in 2002
which was when all the reality shows
were being born.
So I got to see where these people had
their backgrounds from and almost all of
them had their backgrounds from traumas
or from sitcoms or from the world of
fictional shows.
So much so that you were considered to
be like a trader if you were involved in
reality show,
like people,
people got mad at me that saying that
I was taking jobs away from a writers
because I was involved in, in
reality shows. And I was like, oh,
this is hilarious argument.
But these people all came from this world
where you manipulate things in order
to make drama. So they started doing
that to the quote unquote reality shows.
So that's what you're getting.
So this 30 days show that doesn't exist
anymore and supersize me show there,
you know,
you're tackling very complex issues and
you're doing it and it to entertaining
form. And when you do that, there's
some integrity that's sort of like,
it goes by the wayside. But I think
that's right. And that integrity,
I think I had a real example
of that. You, in the end,
you're relying on the people involved to
have a bit of integrity and ethics and
the way they do their jobs.
And I just saw little example this
weekend I was out doing stuff and I did,
uh, to do with the election.
In my company. And we did a,
I did an interview for the local news,
NBC News,
and we were doing some demos of stuff
with people in Santa Monica and um,
they wanted to film one of the people
that were doing it with, you know,
interacting with our thing. Right. But
with our website and at that point,
no, they weren't any people interested
in doing that. So one of the teams said,
why don't we just pretend to be
a member of the public doing it?
And it's really interesting because
they said, no, the producer and the Gen,
they said, no, no, it's going to be,
you know, a real member of the public.
And I thought that was really cool. You
know, they, they obviously want it to go,
they were busy.
They had to get back to the studio.
They were really annoyed that they're
having to wait a long time for an actual
member of the public. But they really
did say no, we were not going to fake it.
And it would've been so easy and no one
would have noticed. And in that moment,
it was literally just that personal
integrity. And it was really cool to see.
And I, I hope that's really
widespread in the news business,
but it was just for me,
a really interesting example of you
can make rules and you can have stuff,
but in the end it's about people
and their choices in the moment.
It is interesting that they
chose to do that with integrity,
but it's also interesting
that someone suggested
they'd not. Exactly. Exactly. Yeah. And
that's the, that's the other side of it.
But it was, I was really pleased
that that's what they decided to do.
I did a show for CBS wants, um, called
game show in my head. And the, uh,
the premise of the show was you would
have this little earpiece in that someone
could talk to you in.
So I would put an ear piece in
the contestants and send them out.
And when they would be standing
somewhere, I'd say, okay, can you hear me?
And they say, yes. All right,
here's what's going on.
And then these two guys came in with
cameras that were holding cameras.
You are a reporter on the news.
Here's your scenario.
Someone called in a Ufo sighting.
They saw a Ufo sighting.
We brought in the cameras.
Unfortunately that person went away.
So when you have to do is convince some
member of the public that's around there
to take that person's place and to say
that they were the ones who saw this Ufo
and you have to get them to say that they
were taking a board this Ufo and that
they were examined by aliens.
And so the guy, you know, it was,
it was kind of funny. They're like, okay,
here we go. All right, how do I do this?
What was shocking was how many people
when you put that camera on them
immediately said they would do it
and immediately started just lying.
Just lying. It was a silver craft.
I mean, all walks of life. Uh,
very few people said no.
That was the most shocking thing
when you had the camera on them.
They just started talking and they started
sort of repeating these iconic images
that you always hear. The discs
shape things, silver with knee,
there was no bolts on it.
They,
they were like going into detail talking
about though the medical examinations
and, and this, this guy who I
think it was a guy and a girl, um,
you know these contestants
who had to do this.
We're just talking to these people and
we will all the producers in the truck,
we're all looking at each other like,
wow, people are fucking full of shit.
This is so weird.
It's so weird how easy it is for some
people to just justify making up a story
just in order for them to be on camera.
But what did you think?
It's because they just,
it's the camera they want to be on the
camera was that they want to please the
other person. They want to be on TV.
Look clever. It could be that as well.
But I think most likely it's,
they want to be on television
so they could go home,
set their DVR and you know, it's on
it. It's not an Automaton, that's me.
I have fucking lion, you know, they
just wanted to be on television.
I think for a lot of
people in this day and age,
that is just some sort of a weird,
ultimate goal.
Just to have that camera on them and
then they go home and see it. Right.
Whether it makes sense or not. And for
a lot of folks, it doesn't make sense.
A lot of folks, you know, they wind the
winds up ruining their lives. You know,
they, they find out how
other people feel about them.
Plus you expose yourself to the critique
of millions of anonymous people filled
with hate,
filled with hate and disappointment their
own life and just ready to spew venom
in your direction. They just can't win
that shit all over you, Steve Hill.
Well,
this is the judge you
this,
we had another thing this weekend.
We went out and made a little film just
to test that out about the elections
going on in, in, in La. And we
literally went up to people and, um,
made up candidates that were
running for Congress and a nice,
what they thought about that,
you know,
and what do you think of Angelina Jolie
running for Congress? And they towed it.
Yeah. This is guide. Yeah. I was so
excited when I heard that. That's great.
You know,
I think she's great and it just,
you can't believe how people just
engage with these things. This is made,
it just made it up and
they just went with it.
Like you were saying with the Ufo thing,
he was like going on about it.
It wasn't just saying, yeah, I
heard about that. That's great.
He was sort of embellishing
it. Just ridiculous. Yeah.
People are fucking strange man.
That's strange range
and that's um,
it's a real problem when it
comes to politics or anything.
When you're allowing people to make
choices that can affect others.
People are weird,
you know,
and a good percentage of
them are really dominant,
uninformed and not interested.
I mean they,
when you say dumb and uninformed,
here's what I think when I say
that, what, when I'm saying dumb,
what I mean is if the human
mind is a essentially a say,
if everyone has the exact same physical
structure, the exact same genetics,
exact same hormonal system,
and one person does yoga every day and
eats healthy and does chin ups in the
morning when they wake up and drinks a
lot of water and the other person sits in
front of the TV, likes to smoke
cigarettes, eats nothing but sugar,
you get to see the results of the one
person being very aware of their body and
taking care of their body
and the other person not.
Will you get that same
effect with the life?
You get that same effect with how
you approach the world itself.
Some people approach the
world through this lazy,
disconnected,
you know,
like pop culture obsessed,
nonsensical,
just pop culture obsessed.
Jamie talking to you, you fuck,
he's a little pop culture,
so not too bad.
Jamie's aware of a lot of other shit too,
but some people just,
they don't enrich their life. They
don't enrich their mind. They don't.
They're not.
They're not curious.
And those people with all these poor
decisions and drug addictions and the
life's a mess,
they have an equal say to the person
who's rational and aware and kind and
objective,
equal say,
and I think that's one of the
weirdest things about communities,
about culture.
It's about to figure out how do you
mitigate the effects of the lazy.
How do you, how do you deal with the
effects of the morons? Like when,
when you have a riot and people start
pulling white people out of cars and
throwing rocks at their heads, which
they've had in Los Angeles in the past,
especially after the Rodney King
beating and things along those lines,
just random white people just attack them.
How do you,
how do you,
how do you allow when you see these things
can happen and then just use that and
it's an example.
It could be a million other things
that are really stupid that people do.
How could it be that one person gets
one vote and another person who is very
aware,
another person is very educated.
Another person who's very kind and very
sympathetic to all walks of life gets an
equal vote. One person could
be a total racist. You could,
you could go to a voting booth with a
tee shirt on that says fuck black people
and you could vote and no one could
stop you. You know, as long as you,
especially if you have a shirt,
sort of like a flannel shirt that's over
the t shirt that says fuck black people.
So you have to really look hard to see
fuck black people and you think you're
getting over. No one can
stop you. You know? And it's,
I think one of the things that they
were trying to work around when they
developed the concept of a
representative democracy there,
the concept of America representative
government. So like, okay,
let's sort of have some filters
in place when you're voting,
but you're kind of voting
on a representative and
the representative sort of
votes
and they interpret what you want.
I think that's,
that's definitely part of the idea.
I think that when you, I mean that,
that point you just made about the,
it really reminds me actually the racist
point you mentioned made there was a
really effective commercial for rock
the vote. I remember years ago in the,
in the UK when I was back
there at the time and they,
they literally had a some image of,
I wasn't images like uh,
a TV ad of a ray of the racist guy,
like spewing racist
stuff. And then the, the,
the tagline for the ad was you'd better
vote cause you can be sure that he will.
And it was a really, you know,
good way of making that point.
But I think that generally, you know,
those kind of people, are they extreme?
I think the idea is that most
people are not, you know,
the kind of extreme end
of it where they're either
totally and where their views
are just completely abhorrent or they
are just completely off the page in terms
of their knowledge. You got, you know,
majority of people who are basically
interested in good things happening.
I think the problem is they just
don't know enough about it. They're,
the information they get is
not interesting. It's not
presented in a good way.
There's other interesting things going on.
They're busy with their life, you know,
they want to get involved.
And so what happens,
and I think this is
happening more and more,
is you end up with a smaller and smaller
group of people who basically control
the political system because the,
the massive
people are just not interested.
They're turned off.
They think that getting involved,
what make any difference.
And so what you end up with is people
with a lot of money, special interests,
those who,
you know,
that kind of professionals of the
political game running everything.
And that actually makes people even less
inclined to get involved because they
see what's happening thing. Oh, well why
should I bother? It's a really bad cycle,
I think. Yeah. And then people
start saying things like,
all the new world order's
and control anyway,
the Bilderberg group is in control anyway.
And there was some,
a thing yesterday that was in
the news where one of the, uh,
members of the Bilderberg Group, uh, in,
I think he used some Dutch guy,
had some impromptu public discussion
with all these people and they start
bringing out all these details
of nine, 11, nine, 11, those,
the building was brought down thermite
and they stay and they circled this guy
and started talking to them. And it's,
it's kind of fascinating, you know, this,
this idea of the Illuminati,
the,
this idea of a small group of people
controlling everyone through iconic
symbolism,
eyeballs inside of pyramids
and all that stuff becomes a,
in a lot of ways, a vehicle for, um,
for feeling unempowered that we're
feeling. That's existing franchised.
That's what's good. I think that's,
that, that's how people feel.
I certainly noticed,
I used to work back in the UK and the
government and I noticed it that I've been
in politics a long time. That's how
people feel that it's even more so here.
I think,
you know,
if you just look today with speaking
on election day in California's the
primaries, everyone's saying it's going
to be the lowest turnout ever known,
was interested because they don't
think it makes any difference.
I think that's a real problem.
And then they feel, you know,
the whole idea of democracies is people
power is that you have the power.
Everyone had,
like you was saying,
everyone has the same chance to
influence things and they have the power,
but that is not what it
feels like to people.
And then every now and then
something comes along with it. Like,
how the hell did that pass?
And then they freak out
exactly like proposition eight,
where they repealed gay marriage.
And everybody's like,
are you fucking kidding me? In
California, you've appealed gay marriage.
The most shocking thing about proposition
eight to me was that over almost over
the, the majority, uh, of,
of black people voted for it.
They voted to my heel.
Gay Marriage. They didn't want
gay marriage, which is, you know,
quite hilarious if you started thinking
about people that have been persecuted,
I mean,
who has been a victim of
unfair discrimination in
this country more than black
people probably know.
I don't know because um,
I wasn't involved in any way, but I've
heard that when you look at the date,
exactly to your point,
that that was one of the reasons,
and that was particularly the case
because it was in the ea when Obama was
running and you had a high
turnout amongst those people.
Precisely because you have the first black
candidate on the ballot for president.
So had more black people voting
and that was one of the consequences.
Yes,
70% I don't know if that's right, but
that's certainly what some have argued.
Do you know how crazy 70% that's the
exit polls said 70% of black people voted
for proposition eight.
That's stunning.
The idea being for a lot of them, that
is, it was, it was a religious decision.
Yeah.
I think that was a big,
that was a big part of the story that's
told someone should tap challenge that
and uh,
what they should do is they should
make some sort of a proposition banning
shrimp,
you know,
like have like have like these big
signs in front of Red Lobster, you know,
with genesis, like whatever, whatever
the quote in the Bible that says your,
because there's four times as many
references to shellfish as there is to gay
people.
It was like,
this isn't like a lot of references to
like you're not supposed to eat shrimp,
but you can go to an all unique
buffet and people right after church.
That's really how we allow it. You're
right, it needs to be stopped. It's bad,
but they can't,
for whatever reason,
the gay thing like really locked on to
people. Like they really got into it.
They really got into it for whatever
reason, you know, the, the gay,
the gay decision,
the decision to stop gay marriage seemed
to be like a one that Jesus was really
serious about that shrimp thing. Then
pick a tooth, pick and choose, you know,
you're not supposed to get tattooed
how many religious people have crosses
tattooed on their body. I mean, that's
a fucking, that's like directly, no,
I didn't know that. Oh yeah.
Tattoos not, yeah. Upon, yeah.
You're not supposed to mark yourself.
Okay.
You're not supposed to tattoo yourself.
That's, that's against God's wish.
But people will tattoo themselves with
biblical verses, which is, you know,
hilarious. Yeah. Well
people are weird. You know,
and my point that I was trying to make
kind of clumsily earlier was that it's
kind of strange that we are so varied
and it's kind of strange that everyone
does get, like if there's three
of us in a room, you know, we,
we have to, we all have to all decide.
And uh, if one of us is retarded,
I mean,
not literally,
but are people with down syndrome or
people that are anyone that has like
mentally compromised? Are they
allowed to vote? I mean, there's,
there's some sort of a test if you apply
that. I didn't know what the rules are.
I think in, in the, in the, in
Britain, it was something to do with,
I think the only thing was if you
in jail, I can't remember. Well,
if you're a felon in America,
we don't ever let you recover.
We don't ever let you recover from that.
So if you're a felon,
you don't get to vote. Yeah. You fucked
up too much. What? You never can. No,
I don't believe so.
Fell.
I'm pretty sure it felons don't get to
vote because Joey Diaz always talks about
that. Don't get to vote. I
know they can't carry firearms.
Yeah.
State felon laws.
Um, I guess it looks like
it's different in every state.
Two states allow felons
to vote from prison,
while other states may permanently prevent
felons from voting even after being
released. So it's different. It varies
from state to state. It's amazing.
Permanently prevent. Yeah.
They lose, uh, they vote.
They cannot vote permanently.
In 11 states. Uh, Alabama,
Arizona, Delaware, Florida, Iowa,
Kentucky, Mississippi, Nevada,
Tennessee.
W coincidentally,
all places I would never
fucking live. How Weird, Huh?
Yeah. You're worried about
the rules? I think the, um,
that is amazing to me that there's
this assumption that there's no
chance you get on can I cut back?
You don't turn it around.
You never make a felony when you're 18.
Like some stupid thing.
You go to jail,
you come out and become like the best
person ever and they're never going to let
you return.
It's ridiculous.
I mean the whole point of what you try
and do with the criminal justice system
and so on is to try and exactly,
you know,
rehabilitate people so they don't
offend again. I mean that is,
and try and get people to that point.
Yeah.
I think people were just so tired of
people just fucking up that they're like,
you know what? This is a good way to
keep fuck ups from voting. Like once,
like the idea that we were talking
about earlier that, you know,
a person could be a racist,
the person could be a complete nutter
and still vote along with a person who's
really kind and educated and
their vote counts equally.
They're in a community that as soon as
that nutter, rob something, it goes,
it's a good way to cut them out of
the system. All right, fuck that guy.
You can't vote anymore.
Which I cast kind of makes sense,
but maybe it's just a numbers thing.
If there's 10 people on an island,
we would have to rehabilitate. The guy
was told the coconuts, we'd have to say,
come on, man, you can't be
stealing everybody's coconuts.
This is a fucked up way to live your life.
If you should contribute,
stop stealing fish,
stop stealing coconuts getting together
and then we'd let that guy be a part of
the case.
By the way,
I think it's an incredibly important
point about about democracy generally.
I think the closer it is to a real
community where everyone knows each other,
right?
Where the decisions are made by people
who can look the other person in the eye
and well that I think
they're going to be better.
I think one of the problems
is that you've got these big,
big systems and that kind of really far
from the human level where that kind of
trust can be established and that is one
of the problems with a lot of things in
government and politics. It's all just
too big and removed from that human scale.
Well that's a problem with a lot of
things when it comes to human beings.
Just diffusion of responsibility that
comes with being a part of a massive group
like war.
Yeah.
The idea that if there's 300 million
of us and a million of us or overseas,
you know, fighting for freedom, uh,
that's sort of like you could deal
with that because it's not happening in
Calabasas. You know, you can,
you could go to work and you get
deal with your life and in your,
the scope of your world,
it doesn't come up.
But you kind of peripherally aware
at this is happening somewhere else.
But if people in Van Nuys,
we're going to war with people in studio
city and it was only a couple miles
away and you had to deal with that,
then it would be something we
would have to try to calm down.
We'd have to try to deal with this. Like
what? What the fuck's going on here?
Like what are we doing
here? We'd have to, it's,
it's something that you have to deal with,
but the sheer number of human beings that
are involved in the world today and in
communities and cultures, it's
just, it's almost unmanageable.
It's an unmanageable for a person who's
not designed for that were designed
essentially to deal with
our immediate atmosphere.
We're designed to deal with small
tribes of people, friends, family,
the people that you know,
the people that you keep close
and when you get past that,
it's just like almost like, what do
we, I don't know what to do with this.
And so we pass the buck
off to some representative.
I think this is such an important point.
I really do believe that.
I think that so many things don't work
because they get away from the point
where you can really know the other
person or the group that you're with.
There's some guy, and I'm in England,
I think it Cambridge University.
It's in research about the maximum number
of people that you can really have any
kind of human relationship
with anyone tiny.
I think he got to a number of 150
Dunbar's number. Is that right?
I see more about it than I do.
I thought that was just a really
interesting perspective on it, which is,
which is that after that it just gets
to diffuse. We're not designed for it.
It's like your phone. Your phone's
only has a certain amount of data.
That old fucking goofy flip
phone you carry around with you.
If you have an older one, like when
those Motorola star tax, you know,
remember those from back in the day.
Big fucking goofy, clunky thing.
I mean that probably only carried
a hundred phone numbers. I mean,
I dunno how many of that,
but the amount of data that you can store
new devices represents the need that
we have.
But we have these same biological
hard drives that cavemen did.
I mean,
they're not really much different than
people that lived a million years ago.
I mean, how much of it has it
changed? I mean, how many, how many,
how much more room do we have for social
relationships? Apparently not much.
Like 50,000 years ago.
And today, if you took a,
a guy who lived 50,000 years ago and a
guy who lived today and you compare the
brains, how much would they vary?
You could take a 50,000 year old man,
dress him up in clothes and sit them
down in a movie theater and you'd walk
right by him. You wouldn't even know
when you're sitting in your seat,
you wouldn't go, Holy Shit,
that's a fucking cave man. I mean,
the guy would look very remarkably
similar to how you look and I look and how
normal folks look today.
Yeah.
We're not designed for this world
that we've created and it's,
it's popped up so damn quick. Yeah,
exactly. It's really the last kind of,
well definitely last a hundred
years, but you know, again,
it's just getting faster and faster.
You know,
this kind of everything becoming really
kind of organize it, they sort inhuman
level
and this mad struggle to sort of organize
it and to try to control it and just
be, just calm it down, get a
handle on the effects of it.
And I think in a lot of ways that's what
you're doing with this Crowdpac thing
with this Crowdpac thing is
you are utilizing these tools,
these tools of the internet and this
instant access to information that we have
today to sort of establish a much clearer
sense of where political candidates
are coming from and what
are their influences as far
as who is financing them,
where is,
where is their money coming from,
where their decisions headed towards what,
what are they,
what are they doing right now?
No.
Yeah, I think that's, that's
a really good summary of it,
which is that basically we think that
when you talk to people about politics,
one of the things they say is that
we just don't know enough about it.
We don't know enough information
generally, but we don't know.
We don't have information we can trust.
We have all this spin and ads and all
the rest of it from the politicians.
We cannot really believe them. There's
all this stuff around on the Internet.
I don't know what to believe.
So what we're trying to do is give people
really objective information that they
can rely on to figure out
where the politicians are
on the issues that they care
about. And the thing that we found from
our research is that is my, um, uh,
one of my cofounders, Adam, who's
a professor at Stanford, um,
has been working on
this for for many years.
And basically what he's shown is that
the best way to predict what a politician
will do if they're elected is to look at
where they get their money and to look
at also who they give money to.
Cause most politicians also going
to donate to other candidates.
So if you look at all that
campaign finance information,
the money behind this politician that
is going to give you the best guide to
what they're really going to do in office.
And it's something that you can actually,
what we're trying to do is like turn
that into really simple information that
you can without kind of reading tons
of stuff and doing loads of research.
You can get a quick snapshot of who
these people are and then in time,
the other thing that we want to do is
make it possible for you to find the
politicians that are really,
um,
good or bad on the issues that you
care about and get involved in their
campaigns. Because the other
thing is that you've got a tiny,
tiny number of people who
are funding these campaigns.
If you look at the total number of
people who put money into politics,
it's a really small number compared to
the number of people who've who vote.
And then the number of
adults in the whole country.
It's a tiny number that are funding
it all. And even within that,
most of the money comes from an even
smaller number and they're paying for all
of this and they're getting
the outcomes that they pay for.
It's basically a transaction.
That's what's really crazy
and so some people say, right,
you've got to get money out of politics.
That's just got to get it
out and obviously that is
something that has a lot of
appeal.
You can see why you'd want to do that.
There's a brilliant guy
called Larry Lessig.
I don't know if you've come across what
he's been doing and he's been arguing
about this for years and he's
been saying he's at Harvard.
Harvard is that he's a brilliant campaign
on this issue of money in politics.
And he's been saying,
if you think about any problem in,
in America today,
whatever the issue is that you care about,
if that's gay marriage or the environment,
or it doesn't matter what it is,
you're not going to get anywhere about
in terms of solving that problem unless
you deal with the first problem,
which is the money because the money in
politics stops the proper solutions from
being developed.
Because what it means is that
you've got these special interests,
whether that's left or right,
it doesn't matter whether it's big
businesses or unions, doesn't matter.
They want their particular outcome and
they're buying it through the system.
So we've got to get the money out and
he's got a campaign around that and he
wants public funding for elections and
so on and all that is kind of a noble
aim,
I guess.
But my feeling is that that's a
really hard sell because you've got a
constitution that says it's free speech.
You're allowed to give money
to politicians, and we can't
just kind of stop that.
Um, you've got to let people
donate to politicians.
And so our take on it is to say,
well, if you can't take the money out,
let's at least dilute the influence of
the people there right now by letting
more people,
making it easier for more people to
get involved and give money to these
candidates.
So they are not dependent on these big
donors with their particular interest.
And that's really what we're trying to
do is kind of make it easier for people
to get involved in politics so
that they can really, you know,
get these politicians off this
hook there on, which is that their,
their dependence on these donors
for their campaign spending,
which means that once they're elected,
it's kind of inevitable that they pay
attention to them rather than the people
who elected them
in Illinois.
A lot of ways it mirrors the influence
that the Internet has had on the news
itself because the news used to be
distributed only through these proper
channels, whether it was NBC, CBS, and
then, you know, the cable news networks,
CNN,
Fox and all this jazz.
But now it's become this
thing where websites develop.
Huffington Post, all
these, uh, young Turks,
which is an internet based new
show and they have no censorship,
they have no restrictions,
they have no influence other than the
ones that they choose to accept or the
ideas that they bring and they have
the same amount of distribution that
everybody else does. And you can
have a website just, you know,
Mike's fuckhead.com and put it up.
And if enough people find
it valid and interesting,
he could have a million hits a day,
unique visits a day.
And it might be more than CNN gets.
And just simply because of the fact that
it's good information. It's, well, you've
shown that with this, I mean, you
know, you're reaching more people
than the most of these, I think
all of these news sites, right?
10 and a half million a month, like more
than just about anything else, you know.
So it's crazy as exponentially
doubling and tripling.
And what's happening is it's all
being done with no promotion. No,
the only promotion is like I let people
know, hey, Steve Hilton's on today.
And then, but just from, yeah,
I mean that's good to hear that from
Twitter and just spreading the word.
But what I was getting at is that like
the same way the Internet has sort of
interfered with the
distribution of information.
Look at what's going on with his Edward
Snowden case is a perfect example.
This massive change in the way the
entire country looks at the NSA and
government spying was done by one man
leaking information to one guy and one
source which spread through
the Internet and then boom,
it blossoms is huge news story.
That was essentially,
if he had sent that same story through
the proper channels to like the New York
Times or CNN,
they would have nord the fuck out of it.
They would have figured out a way to cover
that thing and throw it under the rug
and stable that rug down
and light it on fire.
I mean what he did was figure out a
way to distribute things for this and
through this new channel and essentially
that's what the Internet is doing with
with voting. Before something
like the Internet came along,
it was very difficult to find out who
the influences of all these different
individual candidates where with something
like Crowdpac it becomes much more
easy and that also will change the
way these people interact with,
you know, I really hope
that that is, you know,
we're just at the stumps of
it to be honest. I think the,
the political world is really late
for this kind of change compared to,
like you say with media and other things
and things that we experience every day
in our lives. Like you
know, like travel booking,
you know that they used to be a time when,
you know,
to get an airline ticket you that's is
have a physically go to some shop and
then have these like weird paper to,
you know,
the whole thing just feels so
antiquated and now it's so simple.
It's really light. You were saying
you've got the power to do it,
you're empowered now.
You get it on your phone.
You don't even have to have a ticket.
And that's got a phone
over the scanner thing.
That hasn't really
happened to politics yet.
But that is what we're trying to
do because, and all this as well.
It's not just us, but you know, I think
that we've got something interesting here,
which is this way of giving people
objective information about the candidates
based on who gives them money.
But,
but overall we're part of this movement
of trying to really put power in
people's hands through technology.
And I'm sure it's going to happen.
I'm really sure because people want it,
you know,
they all sick of just feeling that they
don't get any response and these people
have a had control everything
and nothing ever really changes.
And actually the politicians themselves,
in my experience, they, you know,
you'd think,
well maybe I would say this cause I
used to work in politics myself for the
prime minister in the UK.
So I kind of know them.
They kind of used to be my
world that used to be my world.
My feeling is that generally
the politicians actually
hate this just as much as
everyone else.
They hate the fact that they have to spend
so much time raising money. You know,
literally there was this document
that was leaked to the New York Times,
I think a while back from the democratic
leadership in Congress where they gave
a kind of guide to the newly elected
members of Congress about how they should
spend their time.
And it was a recommendation to the newly
elected members of Congress and it went
through how much,
how many hours a day they should spend
with different types of activity.
You know, thinking about policy, talking
to constituents, there's going to be,
half of the time it was four hours
was recommended that they spend on
fundraising. Wow. Right. And so
the people who go into policy,
they don't want to live like that. They
actually hate it. They hate, you know,
being shoved in a room with
is what happens and being,
they call it dialing for dollars,
you know,
like just literally sitting on
the phone trying to raise money.
That's not why they went into politics.
How do they do that?
They just call random people up or do
they have the list of potential donors
give? I don't know cause I've
never done it, but I think they,
I think that's literally it.
They're given less of likely people to
d Dee Dee Dee Dee,
hi,
I'm running for Congress in the 33rd
district and now I'd like to get gay
marriage the fuck Outta here.
What do you think? I think
I'm pretty much like that.
I don't know how to talk to some people
who know more about it, but um, you know,
so,
so I think actually the politicians
themselves and mostly hate the system.
And so I think that, um,
you know, in a lot of,
there's a lot of effort actually in
Congress to try and encourage more small
donors and make it easier for people to
give money because actually that that's
what they want to,
they don't like being beholden to these
big donors and these companies and you
know, they don't like it
any more than we like it.
I think ultimately the idea of leaders,
whether it's presidential leaders
or whether it's a representatives,
I think ultimately that's
going to go away. And My,
my thought about it is that anybody who
really wants to lead everyone else is
probably an asshole. You know? I mean,
anybody who really wants to be the king,
like why do you want to be the king?
Like don't you have things to do?
Don't you have hobbies and
creative pursuits and like what,
why would you want to just be the guy
who gets to control be the one who stands
at the podium, ladies and gentlemen. You
know, that's, that's a weird ego thing.
I think that in 2014 in the world that
we live in today where we're seeing this
much more even distribution of influence.
Yeah.
I think that ultimately that's going to
be one of those things that gets called
into question. Like, why do we
have an Alpha representative?
Why do we have to have
this head and charge?
I really agree with it. I mean, a lot of
the things that I was trying to do, uh,
when I was in the government
in the UK and, and,
and it's kind of part of what we're
doing with Crowdpac is, is you know,
trying to encourage that even distribution
that more even distribution upon
redistribute power from that kind
of traditional sources of power.
And it's going to central leadership,
putting power in people's hands so that
they can control more and more aspects
of their life because then the end
they'll make better decisions overall.
And it's also just be more healthy.
I think going back to what we were
saying earlier about, um, you know, the,
the way people can only know
a small number of people and,
and if you give them power to shape more
of the things that happened in their
lives, I think that that actually
they will take more responsibility.
They'll be more responsible
in a community sense.
You'll just see everything get better if
you take power out of the hands of the
sort of lead it leaders and central
organizations and put it in the hands of
people. Definitely. I
think, I think you're right.
I think there's also an issue
of it being overwhelming.
The amount of information that you
have to absorb whenever you deal with
political issues,
whenever you deal with campaigns,
whenever you deal with new elections,
you know you're given this pamphlet
of different people and the different
propositions that are up for vote
and you just get overwhelmed.
Especially if you're,
if you have a job that's taxing as it
is and you have a family and you know
you're thinking about
golfing on the weekend,
God and learned to go golfing and you're
looking all this bullshit and like, oh,
I can't even pay attention to this.
Is Everything okay right now? Yes.
Well fucking let me just get this over
with and let's hope everything stays okay.
And very few people take
responsibility for what gets voted in.
Yeah, and it is, I think you're right
though. It is really target. It's hard.
It's easy to say, oh, the voters are lazy
or whatever. They should. But honestly,
like you said,
they've got real lives to live and they
haven't got time for all this stuff.
And that is a really big part of why
we want to make it simple. You know,
we are assuming that people want to
spend less time doing this stuff,
not more time. And I think
a lot of the kind of, um,
organizations and people that have
tried to get people mobilized, you know,
civic organization and the kindness,
that kind of thing, you know, it's,
it's worked to a certain extent with some
people, but for the majority of people,
they just don't want to do it.
They can't do it. Actually.
They're literally too busy, um, with
things that are higher priorities,
like their kids and their family
and their job or whatever it may be.
Hobbies doesn't matter. It's stuff
that they choose to do and that's fine.
That's their life.
And we shouldn't kind of require that
you have to spend ages figuring out this
political stuff. And that's
why we're trying to make it
really simple for people,
but based on quite a lot of comp. And
that's what technology allows you to do.
You can take quite a lot of complex data
and information like we're doing with
the campaign finance records,
where it's literally hundreds of millions
of pieces of information and we're
boiling it down into one
piece of information,
which is a score like where
is this candidate on the,
on the scale of liberal to conservative,
where do they sit and where
are they on each issue?
That's what we're trying to
do to make it really simple,
isn't it sort of analogous in a
way to what we were talking about,
about the amount of people that you can
keep in your brain that Dunbar's number
is that if you lived in a small tribe,
if safe,
we all live 50 of us together
in some small village somewhere,
we really wouldn't have votes about gay
marriage and we really wouldn't have
quotes about,
there'd be a million different things
that would never be up for vote,
and if someone really did start micro
managing everyone's lives, he'd be like,
Hey, you know, Mike is an asshole. We got
to kick him out of this fucking tribe.
This guy's trying to get people
to wear purple and you know,
where certain Nike's during different
moon cycles and make tribal rules and
rituals and make all these
things standard. And you
know, for whatever reason,
he doesn't like men sleeping with men.
Like he's got some weird thing, you know,
he believes it's
so true. I just saw agree with that.
One of my favorite things that um,
one of the these experiments
that happened was in Holland.
I think I've got that right.
Um, in, in, in Europe.
And they did this brilliant experiment
with traffic where they, um,
in a town, I think it was
Friesland or something like that,
probably got that wrong.
Um,
where they literally took away all the
traffic signals, all of them, everything,
right? They took away traffic lights,
they even took it, you know, stop signs,
everything, even the,
the markings on the road.
So they took away the white line in the
middle of the road, everything all gone.
And their theory was that without that
kind of external rule making and kind of
stuff going on to tell you what to do,
people would have to kind of relate
to each other as other people and just
figure it out amongst themselves.
So they would, um, you know,
have to look other people in the eye and,
and sort of work it out between them.
And they found they had this
brilliant effect, which was that um,
accidents fell to zero.
The traffic improve,
the traffic speed was lower,
but the traffic flow was much better.
It just worked all around,
all the kinds of things that you try and
do when all these people thinking about
traffic planning and whatever,
they achieved all those aims by
literally taking everything away and just
allowing people to relate to each
other as humans and earth rules.
I thought it was such a great little story
and I think that you could do that in
all sorts of areas.
If you just leave it to people to figure
it out on a small scale where they can
relate to each other,
you just get a much better result.
Isn't that the issue though?
The small scale we're dealing with,
I drove here today.
I live about 20 minutes from here and
in the drive from my house to here,
I didn't know anybody.
I don't know any of those fucking people.
They might not even be real.
They might be robots that were sent from
the government to pretend the MSA again,
Haley, and he would maybe even
the, I don't know them, you know?
So there there's, there's,
there's that issue,
whereas everyone in Friesland or wherever
the fuck that place was in Holland,
those, those people probably all know
each other. You know, it's a small area.
There's not a lot.
When you get to some weird number,
like the 20 million people that are
live in the greater Los Angeles area,
that's too crazy.
It's too,
it's too nutty and there's
nothing less human than a light.
A stop light.
Red Means Stop.
Green means go wait, look
at it. It's green. Go.
I mean,
it's so disconnected from
human interaction and without
it we become crippled.
There's no better chance that you're
going to run into a traffic stop or a
traffic jam. Then if a cop is
directing, if there's a cop,
it's standing there telling you people go
forward, then you people stop. For sure.
That guy's fucking,
that intersection up sideways.
Every time I go into one
of those situations where a
light is down and there's a
cop standing there, it's a fucking
disaster. Whereas if it was just a light,
if just red light,
green light,
everything seems to work cause we're sort
of program to wait for that light and
then go to it. You just, yeah, you can
follow that up. That cop is, they're like,
oh this mother fucker. I look at
it, no wonder this thing's a mess.
It's a person out there telling
us when we can go fuck him.
Who's he asshole fat fuck telling
me when to go and you know,
and there's this weirdness involved and
all of a sudden there's a human element
that's been thrown into
our robot light thing.
And then there's a,
you know,
there's cameras that they were
putting on them for a while,
which were hilarious on the
actual cups. No, no, no, no.
On the lights because they are doing
that too. I think on the cops. Yeah,
they should. They should do that on all
cops because she'd do that on all cops.
Everything a cop does all throughout the
day should be recorded and it should be
untamperable though they shots that.
I genuinely think that's what they're
trying to do. So much abuse. It's,
there's just massive amounts of abuse
when it comes to police officers.
And I think there's a lot
of great cops out there.
There's not that I don't
believe in law enforcement,
but I believe many of them are
abusive fucks and many of them are
psychologically unable to deal with the
demands of an incredibly stressful life.
Yeah, it's really tough. I completely
agree with the way you put it,
that there's tons of them, the
great, and then the others,
the totally abused that position.
And that's another really interesting
example of how technology can be really
helpful, um, in a way, because
you can, you can have the,
I think I got told that they're
trying to do in here the LAPD,
that if you put the cameras on and
you can't mess around with them,
that's a really powerful
incentive. Huge to behave. Right.
Complaints have dropped dramatically and
they've dropped dramatically cause cops
can't be contained anymore. I mean
it's really that simple. It's really,
it really is that simple.
What I was talking about was that
at traffic traffic lights, right.
They were having lights.
Like if you were going through the light
as it was yellow and it turned red,
they would flash. So if your
wheels, we're not, you know, it was,
if they were in front of the line,
you hadn't made it across
before the light turned red.
They would give you a ticket and,
but it would turn out to be a private
company that was actually profiting from
these tickets.
And so they deemed that unconstitutional
and they were removed all those lights.
But people were just in a goddamn uproar.
It was just madness. Everywhere you go,
they're taking, you'd see flashes
going off at traffic lights and all,
it was his revenue.
It wasn't preventing people from running
lights are preventing people from,
you know,
gunning it when the light turns yellow.
It was just just fucking
people out of their money.
And it was just one more thing where they
complicate the system for the add one
more element that makes it one more
thing that you have to think about.
One more little piece of control
and one more dehumanizing aspect.
People like freedom and one of the
reasons why people like freedom is because
freedom isn't just the
freedom to do as you wish.
It's the freedom to not have to think
about a bunch of other shit and be
influenced by a bunch of other shit
that takes your time away and takes your
energy away.
And I think that's where we're at when
it comes to a lot of these propositions
and a lot of these really Uber complicated
things that are involved in our day
to day lives.
It's like we've complicated ourselves
to this point of almost of no return and
where there's very few,
very few
Turnitin.
Yeah.
I think that the thing that happens
then is that they've complicated it,
then it's not working and here's
how we can better try and fix it.
And then the fixing of it makes it even
more complicated and it just gets that.
And then a new government comes in or
a new governor or whoever it may be.
And instead of actually just stopping
and thinking, you know what, this whole,
we just got to rethink the whole
thing and start from scratch and um,
and just not tinker with it anymore and
try and improve it because it's just
going to make it more complicated.
That never happens.
There's never really enough time for
that to happen. They're not there.
They were only thinking about the next
couple of years in the next election or
whatever.
And so things just get even
more complicated and they never,
they never seem to get to
that point weapon. Yeah,
that's really working. Great.
Now my wife and I went out
to this restaurant the other
night and the restaurant
was this, we were noticing that there's
this theme that's going on and a lot of
restaurants where they have like this
rustic thing going on where they have old
school lights,
the filaments in them.
Then they have hardwood tables and
rot iron this and metal that. And,
and I was like,
I think people are sort of reacting to
this fabricated world that we've created
and we long for this simplicity. That's
why there's these shows like, um,
these Alaska shows where people living
on the frontier and they're fucking
collecting wood and fighting off wolves.
It's like we almost long for that
simplicity of above this world.
We've complicated to this
almost unmanageable point.
Yeah, it's definitely true. And
you see and in so many errors that,
I mean it's like food is a,
is a great example where there's all
this kind of stuff about organic food and
seasonal and local and
grow in your garden.
And that whole movement
I think is a reaction.
I mean if you think about food like years
ago, like in the 50s, I think, you know,
it was all about um, you
know, let's have, you know,
those are the kind of TV package,
food and all this kind of industrialized
food that was then seen as better
because it was scientific and hygienic
and like really kind of good for you.
And then people are now just thinking
that it's just really horrible.
This is all the chemicals.
It's disgusting.
Now the movement is all for this
kind of, uh, local organic food.
It made me laugh though because my family
from Hungary and so when I was a kid,
we used to go back to
Hungary the whole time.
It was a communist country and there
were no food stores with loads of choice
and everything. And you would go in the
store and it was just, you know what?
You got just a few sort of vegetables
and it was, it was just very basic. Um,
and now,
but the other day walking around in
San Francisco and there's the kind of
farmer's market thing going on and they
had their kind of ugly vegetables and
whatever put out there and it just looked
exactly like the Hungarian communist,
the food shop. But here in San Francisco,
it's the most expensive, fancy,
amazing food that you can get. But
it just makes me laugh. Really. It's,
I think a lot of it is
just, you know, you know,
a reaction to what's gone
before and we're currently,
I think you're totally right in this
kind of sense of he's just gone too far.
The whole, um, industrialization of so
many different aspects of our lives. Well,
it's also, we're starting to realize
where people live in cities and they,
they look around and they see all these
buildings and they see this asphalt and
they see these telephone poles
and they go, there's no food here.
We have to bring in the food.
Like this is kind of crazy. Like,
and then you'd get on top of a building
and you look around and how far the no
food here area is.
It's pretty God damn big.
And then you look at all the different
people that live in the no food here area
that require food. He like, fuck,
we got to feed these fucking people.
And then you go, where's this water
coming from? And then you go, oh,
it comes from Colorado.
What's the water comes from fucking
what it's comes from the Colorado River.
Oh No.
So the only way we get water in California
is we have to take it from thousands
of way, thousands of miles away. That's
the only, this is a crazy place to be.
Like we w,
W,
W we're in this unsustainable environment
and New People move here every day.
New thousand people every day. Bump,
bump, bump, set up a fucking house,
built this, another structure, boom.
And then we slowly push
out our no food here,
area deeper and deeper into the desert.
And you know,
no one's thinking about where this
goes. And so far so good, sustainable,
go to the farmer's market.
You can get plenty of good groceries,
but very bizarre if
there's somehow another,
some cutoff of our oil supply,
some,
some way where we can't travel as
easily anymore. We're in a real rut.
It's not a good spot.
It's not,
ideally every neighborhood should have
like a couple of acres where it's set up
where you grow food like that.
W Community Garden.
Totally agree with that. There's
a, there's a brilliant guy. Um,
I don't know if you come across
and go with Nassim Taleb.
He wrote this book called the Black Swan,
and he's, he was really, um, he's a,
he's a mathematician and he was
in the financial markets and,
and he really kind of predicted the crash
and understood all that and he's just
great.
And one of his big points is that these
big systems that we've ended up with,
um, the word he uses our, they'd
completely fragile. They're really,
they look kind of big
and, and, and uh, solid.
But actually we're so dependent on
them that it makes us really fragile.
If they collapse or fall over or whatever,
whether that's a company
or some government system,
we really screwed because that we're so
dependent and that's really a kind of
fragile situation.
And so that's,
that's definitely one of the reasons I
sort of love what he writes about and
talks about is that he's arguing for
exactly that kind of thing. You know,
making sure that companies
don't get too big to fail,
not just in the financial sector.
A lot of people have talked about
that with the banks is too big to fail
argument,
but in every area with the food system.
And other types of businesses
where we're so dependent.
If something went wrong we, you
know, we couldn't cope with it.
And when you have small distributed,
it's just like we were talking earlier
about the power of being distributed is
not just voting power and political power,
its economic power, it's social path.
Every type of power.
It's just going to be much better for
us if it's distributed more broadly and
we're a long way from that. It's
actually going in the other direction.
Yeah it's going the other direction
and very few cities are diminishing and
population. Unless there's something
horribly wrong like Detroit where it,
if I, have you ever been to
Detroit? Have not. It's fascinating.
While you were over here in America and
you're, you're enjoying our fine country,
you should go see our biggest disaster,
cause Detroit at one point in time was
this economic stronghold for America.
It's where we built Camaro's and Corvettes
and Firebirds and it was this place
where it was where America
built what it built best,
which is besides buildings,
it's cars in America built cars
and it all fucking fell apart.
It fell apart when they started moving
jobs to Mexico and all the other
countries, it fell apart when they started
producing shittier and Shittier cars.
And when there was all
sorts of complications with
unions and with a million
different problems. And then slowly but
surely they started diminishing these,
these factories. And there's a
really interesting documentary,
I don't know if you've watched Michael
Moore's first documentary, Roger and me.
Did you ever see that?
Roger and me was all about Flint.
Michigan was about his hometown where
they closed down these plants and then
these people went into immediate, massive
poverty and it was a huge, huge issue.
And if you go to Detroit today,
you could buy a house for
$500 and I'm not bullshitting.
They had houses for sale. I was
there 500 bucks. And it's a mess.
It's a real mess.
I mean there,
there's in areas where they're trying
to gentrify these areas and they're
building local businesses and they're
trying to, you know, encourage growth.
And you know what I mean?
If a company wanted to move there,
they have a massive amount of people
that are looking for jobs and cheap land
and it's a good idea. It's a
good place to start, but very,
very difficult to
encourage people to do so.
So Detroit shows how easy
things can fall apart. Yeah.
And there's been a bunch of blogs that
have been created where they've, uh,
websites where they have shown how these
trees and nature are taking over these
areas that used to be populated
where trees are growing those pills.
It's amazing. I remember
that now. Yeah. Bears,
bears are moving into these areas that
used to be at least to have, you know,
towns and bears are slowly started
moving their way into Detroit and it's
fucking crazy. And he'd
say, yeah, but that's,
that shows you how easily it could
all fall apart. Whereas, you know, 50,
60 years ago, here's some, here's
an image of Jamie just put up,
these are trees that are growing
inside of this abandoned building.
It just growing through the floor.
And eventually they'll make their way
through the roof and the roof will rot.
And it just shows you how easy it is
for nature to reclaim areas that human
beings feel like of, well this is a
city now. Now it's the city for now.
You know,
it's not a city now.
It's not permanently a city like
this is trees just go. You ever, um,
go to the airport,
drive down.
Supolvida there's areas where it's really
old roads in these trees have grown up
through the sidewalks so bad
that the sidewalks are, you know,
you can't walk on them.
I mean they're,
they're like ramps because the tree has
slowly but surely lifted up the concrete
of the sidewalk and it's
trying to reclaim this area.
They've put this stupid rock
paste over. Yeah. You know,
I think that's like one of
the best examples of how
easy it could all fall apart
at that point about being dependent
on, on something. Yeah. But it's,
it's interesting cause you got a lot of,
and I've loved going around other and
getting to know other American cities.
I mean they, I mean that's a bad example.
You've got some really great cities,
you know,
the,
that seems to be thriving and working and
that's just really cool places to live
and work. I love Chicago. I thought
it was an amazing car, was fantastic.
Then you've got huge problem with the,
it's just so interesting how you have
a city that is so great in so many ways
and that, and they've got this, this,
this sort of pocket of real poverty and
crime and that's been going on for years
and despite all the other advantages
and they got a lot of, you know,
great economic growth going on there
and so on and people visiting and it's
great,
but they still got this PR,
this entrenched problem with
crime and gun violence and um,
you know, it's just, it's interesting how,
how long it takes for some of these
prompts to be worked out. Yeah,
Chicago is a disaster in that sense.
It's a great city,
but it's also a disaster in the
sense of crime and gang violence.
And I was there,
I was talking to this guy who was a cop
and he was explaining it to me that a
big problem is the drug trade and that
certain gang members were incarcerated
and because they were incarcerated
they created a vacuum that was,
there was a power struggle
to try to fill the vacuum.
That power struggle started this sort of
violent war going on between all these
different criminal factions. And then
you know, it builds up and you know,
he was really kind of interesting
cause he was talking about, he goes,
you know the best way to fix it,
he goes legalized drugs and he goes,
nobody wants to hear about it.
But the reason why they're making all
this money is because they're selling
something that's illegal. And so when
you're selling something that's illegal,
the only people that are doing that
are the people that are criminals.
And he goes,
as soon as you make it legal,
you can deal with a personal choice issue.
And the guy was like very
rational about it and he was like,
you're dealing with a personal choice
issue instead of a crime issue.
But I think that's exactly right.
I think it said one of the more kind of
interesting ways into that whole drug
legalization argument is,
is to think about the,
the social problems that come from
the current rules. Not just, you know,
a lot of times people talk about the
drug use being the social problem,
but actually it's everything that comes
from it, the crime and the gangs. And,
and that's, I think, you know,
the, the most intelligent
argument. Full legalization.
Yeah. And there was a real interesting
article recently about Mexico.
They were talking about the cartels like
hemorrhaging money because they relied
on marijuana trade and
now with legal marijuana,
just the legal marijuana in
Colorado and in Washington state,
and then all the medical places have
massively diminished the amount of
influence that these guys have of the
amount of wealth that they can get from
selling illegal drugs.
Cause people don't need it anymore.
It's just super easy to get.
So like the marijuana trade,
which is one of the most common drugs,
it's kind of drying up for them.
And so they're scrambling to try to
find some other avenues of revenue.
It's pretty interesting stuff because
it's just shows people like this is,
this is what you do when you
make things illegal and it's,
we should have figured it out in
the 1920s with prohibition. I mean,
it's amazing that people are so goofy
today that they still are or are dealing
with the same issue that they kind of
resolved in the 1920s you almost a hundred
years ago,
they figured this out with alcohol and
they have to relearn the same lesson with,
uh, with cannabis. It's just,
it's nutty and it's, again,
it's another thing where it's a personal
issue where you have just too many God
damn laws. You have too many restrictions
on personal for. Exactly right.
And it's interesting,
I think that the, the politicians have
been put off for a long time from,
from doing anything about it,
by the kind of reaction that they'll think
they'll get from certain parts of the
price and so on.
But actually I think that's changing
and it's changing really quickly here in
America.
And the fact that you've got these ballot
measures that are winning in different
states and that's just going
to accelerate, I think,
not just that, the amount of revenue they
pull in with no resistance whatsoever.
Colorado has 39% tax revenue on
marijuana that's sold recreationally,
39% and everyone there is
like, okay, 39% is cool.
They'll be like,
no one's arguing over the
most preposterous sales rate
ever that that is 39% is
fucking crazy. It's basically
the government is a drug dealer.
I mean that's what it is. I mean,
so you're not just taking taxes,
you're fucking a partner. You're a
partner in this 39% is a big partner.
You're at almost 40% okay.
And then they're making over a hundred
million dollars a year in tax revenue
just in the state of Colorado. So when
that kind of money starts coming in,
then they,
that money has influence and then they
have to respect the pot dollar because
the pot dollar is going to be a lobby.
Just like anything else,
just like the pharmaceutical lobby,
just like the natural resource lobby.
Just like anything else,
the pot lobby's going to be legit now
because there's going to be a tremendous
amount of revenue available
and big business there.
There's a big businesses that are
moving into Colorado right now and
establishing warehouse warehouse
spaces in Colorado are just,
they're evaporating,
they're disappearing left
and right because people
just picking them up and they
were, the way Colorado's laws are
set up, in order to sell marijuana,
you have to grow marijuana, so if you
wanted to open up a shop in Colorado,
you'd have to grow your
own stuff and then sell it.
You can't buy it from someone
else and then sell it.
So they're just giant warehouses
everywhere of being scooped up and they're
setting up these massive grow ops and
then they're funneling that money because
it's being sold legally to funneling
that money right back in the state at a
rate of 39%.
It's crazy and huge companies are slowly
but surely creeping their way towards
Colorado because they realize this is,
this is a multibillion dollar
industry and just a couple of years,
you're looking at three,
four, five years from now,
a multibillion dollar industry,
nationwide cut places where they're
having serious money being issues,
serious problems with
generating tax revenue.
All of the sudden all the profits that
are going to illegal sales of marijuana,
now 39% of that money is gonna come
right to the taxpayers are a right to the
tax
blunders. And if they got any,
um, I guess it's a bit early,
but I was just wondering what the,
what they're seeing in terms of
people's behavior that usage,
lower crime, the other drug, is that
right? Lower crime and lower murder rates.
Murder rates have dropped in Denver.
Yeah, of course they're high.
It's an eye they're to, they're
going to get twice. Well,
they're going to think twice.
They're gonna think about it.
I don't need the sheet. That guy's an
asshole, but whatever. It's his problem.
You know? Look, it's, it's
never good to suppress people.
And when you have something
that's irrational, like
marijuana laws, there's it,
it gives people this feeling of
frustration. Does this disconnect?
It gives them this feeling of
being disenfranchised with the,
the people that are supposedly in charge,
you know? And it makes them upset. Like,
why should a grown man be able to come?
If it was only two of us,
we were living on an island
and I was like, Steve,
I don't think you should smoke pot.
If you smoke pot,
I'm gonna lock you in a fucking cage.
He'd be like, you're an asshole. Right?
Like there's only two. What
do you give a shit? What I do,
it's when there's 2 million of us that
you feel like you can get away with.
Something like that, that someone could
come along and say, I'm the sheriff.
And if I find someone's smoking
marijuana and my district,
I'm going to put them under lock and key
and I'm going to make our streets safe
for the children.
All that stupid shit that they say,
well it's just too many numbers,
too many people.
But what I'm interested in is
like just coming to, you know,
I've been here two years now,
but I do get a feeling that
that is a really quite um,
kind of almost mainstream position.
A lot of people feel like that in America.
Maybe it's a California thing,
I don't know.
But then I'm interested why
the libertarian movement in a,
the political expression of that kind of
attitude is the libertarian party that
candidates, they, they
don't seem to get anywhere.
They don't seem to do well even though
that kind of attitude feels to me like
it's really very kind of true to the
American approach to things and is shared
by a lot of people.
Like I kind of hear that a lot.
I think it's slowly but surely
starting to gain momentum.
But I think the Internet's
influences barely,
barely two decades in 1994 to 2014 right.
That's,
that's the realistic take on it.
But the real impact as far as
like social impact, I would,
I would say it's probably a decade.
10 years is not that much time.
And then in that decade how much of it
has been concentrated on social change
and how much of it's been
concentrated on porn? You know,
how much of it is concentrated? I look,
we can see tits anytime you want now. Woo.
And this new found freedom, this new
found ability to access information,
it's just,
it's going to take a while before I
think people are evolving right now.
I really do socially, um, at a,
at a rate that's just unheard of is
never the kind of movements that you're
seeing now whether you
agree with them or not,
whether it's Operation Wall
Street or whether it's a,
anytime there's a social change or
social movement in this country,
whether you agree with it or not,
it's fascinating to step back and watch
this swarm of activity that takes place
because of any issue that comes
up now that really couldn't,
couldn't happen before without,
you know,
you'd have to have like a physical
meeting you'd have to have,
people would get and someone to have to
have a megaphone and we'll we need to do
is take back the streets.
Well we need to do is make the world
safe for our children and we need to get
out of Vietnam. Yeah. You
know, and then you know,
the cops come and break it up and hose
everybody down and they would shut down
the problem.
We can't do that anymore.
You can't shut down the problems
because the problem exists on reddit.
The problem exists on millions
of people's Twitter accounts.
They're posting things.
There probably exists on Facebook.
The problem exists anytime there's
dissent that dissent sort of encapsulates
an entire group of people that share
these ideas and they can feel freely
communicate.
And I think they're just starting to
realize that they can freely communicate
the way they can and unfortunately a
lot of them are annoying. Unfortunately,
a lot of people that have fit figure
this out or annoying and you see these
really dumb ideas that
spread like wildfire,
wildfire and a bunch of idiots
are behind it. And it's,
that's fascinating to watch too.
But I think ultimately when
it all balances itself out,
we're going to deal with a much
more informed, much more educated,
much more aware,
much more socially conscious society
than we have ever had in the past.
I think a decade from now to deck,
two decades from now,
we're going to see the rewards of this.
And I'm very optimistic. I like it
that, that way of
thinking about it. And I,
I agree and I guess what we w w the
way we're thinking about it is that,
that we want to kind of,
now the next step really is to
really take that energy and,
and really direct it into the
heart of the political system. Mm.
Not kind of on the edges of it.
We've kind of protests and, and, um,
and sort of social movements, but really
getting into the guts of the, of the,
of the way laws are made and
the way the country's run,
the states who were on cities are, and,
and, and kind of injecting it into the,
into the real heart of power.
I think that's gotta be the next step.
Yes. I, I agree. And I hope
that it can be done. I mean,
I wonder if the way technology
is advancing and the way
technological innovation
seems to exponentially increase,
if there's some way to manage
things in a way that's sort of,
um,
not discovered yet or sort of hasn't been,
no one's figured out a way to
sort of organize this whole thing.
In a way that's much clearer and now
we're dealing, it's almost like code.
Like do you remember what code used
to look like when you used to use dos?
And if you use an old computer
yet an mtor, everything
had command prompts. Yeah.
But then someone came along like xerox
figured out this graphic user interface.
It just, Whoa, fuck all that. Just
to see that thing. Just double.
Just press twice when you
want that to open up and boom,
and then you'll see a graphic
representation of what you want.
That's a much more simplistic element.
You don't have to look at all the code
behind what you're doing when you're
using Microsoft word. Uh, cut all
that shit out. Let's just see. Let's,
let's make it real simple. And if we could
get, get it to that in politics, like,
okay, what would make, what would,
what would we have to do to make more
money go towards school and less money go
towards war. Like is
that, is that a way it,
was there a way we could work that out?
If you look at how much money
is being spent in the Iraq war,
how much money's being
spent in Afghanistan,
is there a way to take 30% of
that and put it into our schools?
Because my God, the school system would
radically change our education system,
would radically change the amount of
people that would come out of these
educational systems
that were more balanced,
more aware,
had more nuanced perspectives,
would radically change our country,
would radically improve like
over the course of a decade.
If you could just figure out a way to
put that kind of power in people's hands,
what they choose to do.
Well,
I think the way that you do that is,
it goes back to what we were saying
earlier is is actually literally doing it
by, by getting rid of these
kind of big organizations,
central government organizations that
try and run the whole system from some
office somewhere that's
completely removed from the,
from the parents and the kids that was
actually using the schools and and really
give responsibility for this.
The way the schools operate to local
communities so that they can try things
out.
Because every kid is different.
They learn in different ways and whatever
nature it feels to me like when it
comes to education, we've got this
approach which is someone has decided,
you know,
this is the theory,
this is how we're going to get kids to
learn whatever it may be and we're going
to try and have a kind of common
application of that in every school and
everyone's going to teach the
same way and that's great.
And I just think that the
evidence shows that is not right.
It doesn't work for every kid and you
want to have a system where you know you,
you've got much more ability to experiment
and try things out and adapt things
to each, each, you know, different type
of child and the way that they learn.
And I think we need to see a lot more
kind of smaller schools where they're much
more kind of community run uphill.
I sang with the gardening.
I think sort of a community approach to
these things is going to be the way to
do it.
You definitely need the money of course
to sort of have high quality as well.
So I agree with that.
It's just that if you just put more money
into the current system of organizing
schools,
I don't think you'll get
the kind of benefit that you
could if you actually gave
the power of the system and took it away
from the people at the center and put
it in the hands of people locally
that that's how I would do it.
And if they did that you could also see
the results positive and negative and
imitate the positive ones.
You could see like these people have an
approach and their approach is more sort
of Waldorf school based and
less electronics and wouldn't
toys and interacting with kids and
look at the benefits like, man,
all these people are
coming out so creative.
But then there's another place in San
Francisco that's much more tech involved.
Everybody has an iPad and all these kids.
Well we'll leave it as
a benefit there as well.
I mean I think schools are a huge issue.
The massive underfunding of education.
This country is a huge,
huge issue and it's,
it's madness and it's almost like sort
of ensuring that poverty and that this
was going to be right. You
know what I mean? Yeah.
I done a lot of it is the kind of
people that go into teaching, you know,
you really, you'd want the
best people, the smartest,
best people going into teaching.
It's like the most important job
that get paid $20,000 a year. Right.
And that is not going to get that if
you'll pay those kinds of, you know,
it's really kind of obvious.
We apply that in every other kind of area.
You kind of know that if you pay more,
you get something better generally.
And I think that that is a huge part
of it is actually if you, you know,
trying to get the best people in the
countries that have done really well.
I think that Finland is a good example
from what I know. I'm, you know,
I spent quite a lot of time this when
I was in the government. Finland is a,
is a place where it is the cultural
thing. If you know a really, um,
admired an esteem thing to do and well
rewarded is to go and be a teacher.
It's like one of the best things
you can do. And that's true.
I think of a lot of the
Scandinavian countries and
they have better results as a
know thanks to that.
So you've got to just get the
best people to go into teaching.
That's really important in this country.
The prohibitive cost of higher education
is shocking when you start thinking
about how much money it
costs to go to college,
how much money it cost to get a degree,
and you accumulate student loans
that are almost insurmountable.
How many people get out of
college in this country?
It's amazing that the figures are just
unbelievable. They are so in debt,
just stunningly in debt.
Like I have a friend who is in
his 50s and just paid off his,
his, his uh, 50s. Yes. Wow. Just
paid off from medical school.
This isn't fucking insurmountable debt.
Insurmountable debt forever. Yeah,
just slowly but surely chipping away at
hundreds of thousands of dollars in an
educational debt. It's
really amazing. I mean,
one of the things I'm doing right now is
teaching at Stanford a little bit and,
um, and it's just, there's,
there's a kind of good point,
which is that it seems to me that
the students are so much more,
um,
hardworking and motivated than the ones
that will certainly than I was not seen
diversity,
but you know,
it was all free when we did it in
the UK and here it's not anymore,
but it was when I was at college and here
when they're paying so much for their
parents are paying so much, they take
it really seriously and that's great.
But the, the amounts of money involved,
I just staggering. Really unbelievable.
Especially when you get to law
school or medical school or you know,
any really expensive school.
Stanford,
you know, that's a very
prestigious school. It's going to,
cause it must be ridiculous.
I mean,
how much does the kid have
to pay a year to go to,
cause they have a lot of, um, uh, they do,
they do a lot of great work to kind of
make it possible for kids without the
money to go.
So they do a lot of grants
and scholarships and I don't
know how that all works
out. Well that's what it's
it's, but it's a huge amount.
Yeah. That, that's nice.
And it's beautiful to hear that
they do something along those lines.
And it's also beautiful to hear that,
uh,
I believe it was MIT has released
all of us, it studies online.
You can take all of its
classes online for free,
essentially get an MIT education through
your home computer. Just very nice.
It's very nice that, that, and you,
if you think about the amount of access
that people have to higher education
today when it comes to online courses,
when it comes to just papers that they
could read and download documentaries,
they can watch different things that they
can read. It's, it's kind of incredible.
Yeah.
And it's actually really powerful in
not just thinking about America but um,
and people in the, in the states
who wouldn't have had that access,
but actually all over the world, it's
this, that, you know, in Africa where you,
you're just able to bring, you know,
instruction and the, you know, the,
the best people in the world,
the best teachers to the
most remote village in Africa
is completely staggering.
Yeah, it is. It is interesting.
And I've always had a
fascination with the,
the power that someone has in the position
of being a professor and especially
professor with tenure where
they have this, you know,
kind of this job that essentially it's
very difficult to get fired from. I mean,
you have to really do something really
fucked up. Yeah. To lose your position.
And because of that,
some of them,
and I've had friends that
have had these professors,
some of them get these incredibly arrogant
attitudes and they push their ideas
as if their doctrine,
right.
And they push their own political
ideas and their own ideology.
Oftentimes a very left wing liberal agenda
to the point where it just infuriates
certain parents and infuriates
people who disagree with these ideas,
who gets silenced because you know,
it's the professor's word and that is it.
In my class, this is how I
feel. It was not education.
I mean the, you know, to me,
yeah.
The whole point is you should be equipping
the students to think for themselves
and to, and to kind of come
to their own point of view,
but give them the tools that
they can do that with and, and,
and go out and then use that knowledge
and ability to do great things in the
world. Not to kind of tell them
your point of view. I mean,
that's where you can tell
them your point of view,
but make clear that it is your point of
view and there are other points of view
and it's up to them to
decide what they think.
Yeah.
But that lack of,
that humility is oftentimes lacking when
you have a person that has absolutely.
That's right. There's no
kind of accountability there
because it's just, you know,
they don't have to deliver any.
That is like one of the complaints right
about the amazing thing though.
I loved the speech that um, uh,
Mike Bloomberg gave the other, I think
it was last week, did you see this?
He went to Harvard and
he gave a commencement
commencement speech I think to
Harvard where he really attacked him on
this point and said that they had this
kind of liberal bias in the,
in the faculty there that was
just really bad. And the, yeah.
And he had this great piece of data,
which was that if you look at,
it's going back to campaign finance,
if you look at the campaign finance
records, because that, you know,
everyone's donations,
it reported and when you,
when you make a political donation,
you have to say what your
occupation is so you, you, you know,
it's quite easy to,
to look at types of professions or
whatever and where their money goes.
And he got this piece of data,
which was that if you look
at the political donations
of Ivy League faculty and
staff, and you look at where the
money went in the last election,
the figure for how much
went to Obama was 96%.
So it was like this total liberal
dominance and he said that is just not
healthy. That is not what the
university is supposed to be.
The problem is the alternative was far
more offensive if they went to John
Mccain and Sarah Palin did that 4%
is the problem. Believe it or not,
in this country. I mean, Obama's,
I'm not a fan of what this
administration has become,
especially when it can turn when it can.
Uh,
it deals with freedom of the press
when it deals with whistle blowers,
when it deals with a spying on Americans,
like all the revelation that we found
out about the lack of privacy that people
have. I'm not a fan of
that at all, but God damn,
having Sarah Palin as the vice president
of the fucking United States would have
been disastrous.
Having a,
an old man who's playing poker where
they're talking about going to war with
Syria, who's literally sitting on
his phone playing poker, you know,
I mean, what the fuck that was a president
that, that was the vice president,
those two dummies. I mean,
that's a disaster. That's a
fucking God damn disaster.
So of course the most educated amongst
them went for the lesser of two evils.
Being Obama,
being a guy who was a very articulate,
intelligent guy who's a whore. I mean,
essentially that's what Obama is.
He's what he is,
is a guy who's very intelligent,
articulate guy who had these
ideas and promoted this ideology,
got into office and did essentially
exactly what Bush did. I mean,
in worse when it comes to whistle blowers
and stuff, yeah, yeah. And well, you know,
all the things that we're going to do,
we're going to close down Guantanamo Bay.
We going to get out of Afghanistan.
It turns out most of it was bullshit.
Most of it. I mean, when you talk to
people that are, that are journalists,
this country has a horrible record and
this administration has a horrible record
on freedom of the press, a horrible
record on punishing whistle. And it's, uh,
the, the, the lack of,
the lack of respect for,
for journalism and freedom of the press
is very disturbing to people because
what,
what is journalism truly well,
what it truly is is
you're exposing reality.
What a true journalist is
doing is exposing reality.
When you punish people for doing that,
when you punish people for blowing
the whistle on what is essentially
unconstitutional activities like the NSA
spying on every single fucking person
on the planet, I mean,
that's unconstitutional.
When you record everyone's phone call,
that's not what we want.
And when the government supports
things like that, I mean, how,
how is this the same guy that
was like, hope and change? How,
how is this the same guy?
Well,
he's the same guy because the people
that fucking got him in the office,
or the same people that
got Bush in the office,
the same goddamn influences and things
like Crowdpac things that you're trying
to do. What expose that for folks? Yeah,
the, I mean, that's the idea
we're trying to be and you know,
it's really important that we're,
um, you know, it's, you know,
we just going to nonpartisan.
So while we've got a strong point of view
about the system generally and how we
can improve it, you know, we don't really,
it's very important. Don't take sides.
We don't have a point of view as
a company about individual issues,
but I think that we do really care
about, um, changing the system.
And I think that one of the,
one of the things about the press that,
that sort of happens, and I've seen
this, I'm kind of both sides of it,
is that there tends to be this kind of
coziness that develops with a lot with a
lot of the press, particularly the
traditional press where, you know,
they want to have access
to the politicians and the
politicians want to get
their message out and it
just gets quite kind of cozy.
And so that whole role of
investigation and exposing things, um,
kind of sometimes takes a backseat to
having a good relationship so that you can
get your message out and that,
and they get access.
And I think that that's one of the things,
again,
that's really helpfully being changed
by technology, like you were saying,
which is that, um, you've got people
who are able to get, you know, to,
to do that job of investigation without
having to be part of some cozy group
around the politician.
Yeah.
He's going to lob softballs
and every politician, you see
it from the politician's point of view,
their point of view, and it's, you know,
there's a lot of truth to it is that
they're trying to do stuff. It's really,
really hard. You know, trying to deal with
some of these problems is difficult. Um,
there's incredible expectations.
Um, you get chip for what, you know,
just trying, um, you're totally under
scrutiny. Your life is under scrutiny.
It's a really,
really hard job.
And they feel that the increasingly
the media and the press and are just
interested in the trivial aspects of it
and who's up and who's down and they're
not really interested in kind of exposing
the complexity of some of these issues,
blah, blah. So that, that's
how the politicians see it.
And then on the other side,
and that's why they end up trying to,
you know,
have a relationship that enables them to,
in the,
in there and the way they see it to,
to explain what they're trying
to do a bit better so that they,
so people kind of give them a fair
hearing. So that's why that all happens.
And you know, there's a lot of, there's
a lot of truth to that. To be honest.
It is difficult what they're
trying to do. Um, whatever,
whatever your Liberal
Democrat or conservative or
does it makes no difference.
It's difficult. Governing is
difficult. It's complicated.
The problems are complicated.
Everyone's got their point of view,
you're kind of being screamed at and
yelled at the whole time and it's hard.
Now look, they choose to go into it so
we cannot feel sorry for them. You know,
they make that choice. Like you
said, they have that kind of,
I'm going to be the leader and I'm
going to go there and sort things out.
So it's the choice that they made,
but it is difficult and that's
why they want to, you know,
try and can't control the message I
think because they feel that a lot of the
time they don't get a fair hearing.
Well that makes sense in some ways,
but it doesn't make sense from the point
of view of the people that are in the
position of being a journalist. If you're
in the position of being a journalist.
Fair enough. Yeah, you, you're, your
whole position is to expose inequality,
expose violations of the constitution.
And when you are,
you're in one of those places where you,
whether it's for CNN or Fox News
or whoever you're working for,
if you get to sit down with Dick Cheney
or you get to sit down with Obama,
you're already muted. You're already
neutered, you're already silenced.
You don't get that chance to pro.
They're never going to have Glenn
Greenwald sit down with Obama and an open
internet forum that airs in real time
live. They would never agree to that.
They would never agree.
Greta. This way, it actually, cause it's
a really different tradition in England.
When you look at the way that interview,
if anyone watches a TV interview of a
politician in England is so different to
what you get here, they're really
aggressive with them real and you really,
really, really aggressive. And,
and the kind of softball stuff is actually
kind of embarrassing for a journalist
to do that.
And there's a different tradition.
Well, we used to have
that. It's really true.
I've really noticed that
they shot a few people,
Park some cars on railroad
tracks with families in them,
and then people kind of
stopped doing that. Um,
I think that guys like Glenn Greenwald
who lives in Brazil and gets to sort of
attack America from a distance, you
know, at least until they find him. I,
I think, uh, what guys like
him are doing with, you know,
he was the one who helped,
uh,
Edward Snowden release all of
his documents and the, these,
these new players in this whole game,
these outsiders that don't have to cozy
up don't have to be a part of this, uh,
this nepotism that we're seeing
with the big ones. I mean, any,
anybody that's in any
sort of a large group,
Fox and CBS and NBC,
you're a part of this wacky system.
You're a part of this system
that's not going to expose these.
It's going to let these people get
their message out. Because if you don't,
you're not going to get the big names.
If you don't get the big names,
you're not going to get the ratings. And
then those big names, you can go to Fox,
those big names are
going to go over to CNN.
They're going to go somewhere else and
you're going to lose this, this, yeah,
that's exactly how they, it seems to work
here. That's what I've noticed. Yeah,
it is.
It is it.
And I believe it's getting exposed and
I believe it's getting exposed in a way
today that just wasn't happening
20 years ago. 20 years ago.
You would just be frustrated and you
would just go off and you'd write a book
and everybody go, Oh, he's another look
at the fucking crazy book that guy wrote.
And you know, some people would read
the book and say it was amazing,
and other people would just ignore it and
new revelations would take place along
the way. And whatever had
happened would be forgotten.
And then the politician
would get out of the office.
And I think George Bush is the last
guy to sort of skate away like that.
And you know,
now he sits around and paints weird
pictures and slowly goes insane.
Have you seen the things he's doing?
He's slowly going insane. I mean he's,
he's painting pictures and
he's locked in this world of,
he's essentially in a prison on a
ranch. I mean, that's what he is.
He's constantly circled by secret service
agents. He's hated all over the world.
He's at least indirectly responsible
for over a million deaths.
This one guy,
they're pinning it on him and Dick Cheney
and his administration and this sort
of pyramid of events.
And this guy feels that shit and he's
just sort of wandering around on his
fucking ranch, painting himself, staring
at himself in the bathroom mirror. I mean,
it's really,
really weird stuff and I
think he's probably going
to be the last guy that ever
skates off into the sunset with
this, this, this knowledge.
I think Obama's going to be
held accountable for a lot
more than Bush ever was.
And I think whoever's
next is truly fucked,
whether it's Jeb Bush or whether it's
whatever, you know, new Democrat,
they try to sneak into, I
don't know, Hillary Clinton,
I don't know what they're trying in 2016
and we won't know for a while because
they have to vet out. Everyone's fucked
up. Vices and skeletons in their closets.
And in this day and age,
it's almost, sometimes it's
terrible. I think by the way.
Cause that's what I, one of the reasons
that so many people get put off from,
you know, cause a lot of the complaints
you hear about politics as well,
we just get the same kind of people.
They're all kind of, you know, very, um,
kind of similar to each other.
And there's a particular type
of person that goes into it.
And actually a lot of people who I think
could make a really good contribution
don't do it exactly for that reason.
They just didn't want to live under
that kind of spotlight and can't,
that's just normal human
beings. And they've got stuff
that they had fun. Right.
It's kind of fun in their
life. I mean, people that have
had fun, you know, I mean,
you can't one gay affair when you're
20 years old with a guy for a couple of
weeks and you're fucked
for the rest of you.
That guys out there waiting to talk shit
about you. If you run for president,
you know there's one time you did a little
bit of heroin when you're on the row
with a bunch of your buddies. You
know we were at, you're in college,
you tried heroin. Oh, that's
fucking college buddies.
Ready to write a book about you
doing heroin. I mean there's a,
it's a weird time when it
comes to exposing people's
pasts and this idea of this
perfect person from the cradle to
the grave running for president is
preposterous. You don't want
that person, that person,
if they've never made any mistakes,
that means he never taken any chances
if they haven't taken any chances they
haven't lived. And I'm not talking
about mistakes like victimizing people,
horrible things that are completely
unconscionable that you wouldn't do and I
wouldn't do murder and
robbery and kidnapping,
all sorts of terrible things
that are just massive, you know,
ethical errors that just shouldn't be
ever tolerated from a person's character.
Just little things like
here's a perfect example.
There's a woman who's running for mayor
right now in Mississippi and apparently
when she was younger, she was a
prostitute. And it, this is a,
it's a big story that,
you know,
folks are trying to figure out like
what is, is that okay? Like how do we,
how do we handle this?
Like what do you do about a person who
had made mistakes when they were younger?
Like what is, what is the answer
to this? And no one really knows.
They don't really have the answer to
that and trying to figure out like when,
what is happening in the,
in that is it,
is it I'm playing against
her or what's this for sure.
She's in Mississippi and
she revealed it herself. Um,
she revealed that she was a former
prostitute and she was a prostitute,
like I believe it was 30 years ago.
And she met her husband
while he was a John and, uh,
he was one of her clients and,
uh,
she married him and she hasn't been a
prostitute since and now she's running for
mayor. And it's, it's a,
it's, it's quite fascinating.
I think it's interesting and
I think in a lot of ways, um,
you could see that and think this person
is actually really well qualified to be
an office because obviously, you know,
going through those sorts of experiences,
we'll give you a sense of empathy for,
you know,
the tough lives that some people have
and this and the second sentence at the
end up putting them in that situation
and it probably makes you better not was,
well not only that,
what she did was totally legal as well.
She was an illegal brothel in Nevada and
it was over 30 years ago and she hasn't
been there since.
And the idea that this person is not
allowed to make errors and that she
wouldn't have developed like a lot of
empathy and character and she wouldn't
have to think that's right.
Yeah.
I'm a more balanced perspective than
a person who's grown up in a very
privileged household with very
rich, wealthy, connected people.
And then they got him to an Ivy League
school and then he became a member of
skull and crossbones and Blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Instead of that,
well,
you have person who's who was 14 and was
pregnant with a child and had to take
care her child and her parents
died.
And she had,
was forced into a situation where she had
to earn a living and she didn't have a
lot of options and this was one
of her options that she chose.
And how could you judge someone who's
a teenager that makes those choices?
I mean, I don't think he
can. And I think this person,
I mean good for her that she stepped up
and talked about. I think it's great.
And I again,
it's kind of interesting that some
types of early childhood adversity,
a kind of okay for your political resume.
Yeah.
I came from a poor family and, but
broken home. What about Bill Clinton?
And it's okay, that kind of, um,
difficulty is, is acceptable.
But then there's this other category
which is just as character four tracks and
drugs and whatever. They're just his
character forming potentially. But, uh,
not acceptable. Yeah, the sacs ones,
the wackiest one ever
because it's totally legal.
Like save this woman had,
you know,
x amount of clients per month.
If she just fucked a bunch of guys,
you know, everybody would be like,
Gosh, she was young, she was young,
she was getting wacky, but fucking a
bunch of guys for money is a problem.
But if she just massaged
guys, no problem. I mean,
if she gave them pleasure by rubbing
their bodies by rubbing your shoulders and
backs, no one would have an issue with
it. But by doing something to their penis,
by the way, posture,
it was one of the guys,
one of the clients running for
office and it was, you know,
it's okay to be a client.
That's fine. Sure that you know,
something you'd be proud of. But if
that was kind of exposed or whatever,
that wouldn't be a barrier. Sure. Even
10 years ago, forgot about 30 years ago,
10 years ago, the guy went to a
prostitute and said, listen, I was horny.
I didn't have any options. I had a few
bucks. I paid someone to touch my penis.
People would go, yeah, exactly. Totally
sexist kind of way of
thinking about this act.
Should sex should be legal to sell.
That's what I think.
I absolutely 100% believe that
prostitution should be legal.
I wouldn't want my daughters to do it.
I wouldn't want my friends to do it.
I wouldn't want loved ones to do it,
but I wouldn't want them
to work at Wendy's either.
I wouldn't want them to work on the the
the people that you see on the highway
picking up dirt or a picking up
garbage by the side of the road.
I wouldn't want them to be
pouring asphalt in the hot summer.
I wouldn't want anybody
to work at difficult job.
I think emotionally it's got
to be incredibly difficult
to have sex with someone
that you don't want to have sex with,
but I don't think it should be illegal.
It's legal to have sex with people.
How the fuck could it be legal or illegal
to pay to have sex with people or have
someone pay you to have sex with you?
It seems ridiculous.
It seems just as ridiculous
as making massage illegal.
Yeah. I don't, I don't know.
I honestly haven't thought about it
enough. One of the things that, um,
I definitely feel strongly about is
that if we're going to make that kind of
decision,
the sex trade,
the sex trafficking trade needs to be one
of the ways you think about it because
that is just so evil and
disgusting, completely evil,
completely disgusting. And
whatever decision you make has
to make that better, not worse.
And I don't know, I haven't
really thought it through enough,
but it's a very good point.
That's a very good point.
I think it would probably be far less
demand for sex trafficking for illegal sex
trafficking if prostitution was legal,
if adults could make that decision.
If some woman, you know, was in a
situation which was like, you know,
I'm reasonably sexually attractive and
I make x amount of money per month doing
this, I can make that same amount in
a day having sex with people. Okay,
I'll just do that. You know, if, if
it's, if it's a woman's choice to do so,
and some women would have
no problem with that choice.
The real problem of course
is victimization is a
real problem is exploiting
young people.
Victimization and objectifying women,
but does not already take place and
isn't part of what objectifying women.
That part of this issue is the,
it's very difficult for some
people to find sexual partners.
So there's like this thing
with this Elliot Elliot Rogers,
this crazy kid that shot up everybody.
Incentibox Santa Barbara. The, the,
the nuttiest response that I've
seen to this, the craziest,
most infuriating response is by these
people that believe that if women weren't
so stuck up,
this guy wouldn't have gone on a rampage
because he would have been able to have
sex with more people,
but it would have been able to get
people to have sex with them. Who's,
that's pickup artists and the women,
these women hating fuckheads
there's, there's a bunch
of guys that they're there,
the operate under this, um, this
guise of being for men's rights.
And you know, it's Kinda funny cause
I didn't even know there was like,
there's a thing called an Mra.
It's a men's rights advocate or activist
and it's an insult from feminists.
I got called an Mra once and I was like,
what the fuck does that mean? So I,
I had a Google Mra men's right. And I
thought it was ridiculous that, wow,
how could you be a feminist but be making
fun of someone who's into men's rights?
Like shouldn't we all have rights? I
mean it shouldn't, shouldn't there.
But then I started looking into these
men's rights guys and I go, Oh okay,
I see what's going on.
And yet they're more ridiculous.
It's not the kind of radical feminists,
new stuff. Like, cause there's,
there's some campaigns that make some
good points about [inaudible] child
support. Yes. And they're off to divorce.
I agree with that 100% but there's,
they go way further than that and they
go into relationships and they go into
the way men are treated versus
the way women are treated.
People are treated in,
in bad ways,
by bad people and in good ways by
good people. But if you're a shithead,
people are not going to like you.
Right.
And just because you're a shithead
and people don't like you,
it doesn't mean women are assholes.
It means your undesirable.
And one of the reasons why you probably
undesirable is because you have a
terrible attitude about things.
And this terrible attitude about things
is not going to change. You know, it's,
it's not going to change because
women have sex with you. Like your,
your attitude sucks.
You're not a pleasant person.
There's a lot of people
have shit personalities and
they get involved in this.
Men versus women did that has
nothing to do with men versus women.
What kind of things do they, I mean
the mens rea, what does that, well,
like Saint Cooling, is there a, you know,
it wasn't so much nonsense. They're the,
I don't even really want to
get into it because some of it,
some of it is so fucking stupid and I've
been reading these things over the last
couple of days and I'm trying to erase
them from my memory because some of these
poorly written articles by these
men are so stunningly stupid.
Like one of them was,
this guy was talking about how he was
around this 60 year old man and this 25
year old woman who is his,
uh, his incredibly hot wife.
And that this 25 year old
woman was insulting this man
and you know that this is
this,
this is the anguish that this guy had
a deal with and how horrible it is and
this is what men have to deal with.
And I was like,
that might be one of the dumbest fucking
arguments I've ever heard in my life.
First of all,
what if it was a 25 year old man in
a 60 year old woman that was this old
wretched creature that this guy
was forced to fuck for money?
Like would you be on the man's side
of the woman's side then? Which,
which position would you take there?
Of course this woman is going to
say shitty thinks this old man,
she's not supposed to be fucking him.
She's supposed to be having sex with a
25 year old man or a 35 year old man or
someone reasonably close to her age
where they would be naturally sexually
attracted to each other.
What you're dealing with is a bizarre
situation where someone has sort of
circumvented the system by
acquiring money. Yeah, exactly.
And by acquiring money.
This guy's figured out a way to get
some 20 year old hottie to marry him and
yeah, she doesn't like it.
So she could planes and um,
I'm reading this and I'm like,
does this guy who the fuck is this guy
writing this article talking to who are
his friends? Like why? How is that
an argument? Yeah, that is nuts.
I don't even want to pull the article up.
I don't want to reference it.
I don't want it to fair enough.
But it's just what you're dealing with
with these men is a bunch of nit picky
shitheads with terrible personalities
that are complaining about men getting a
bad rap in this world.
If you do well in this life,
you have an amazing chance as a man of,
of being sexually successful, of having
a great life of not being persecuting,
of not being raped, of not being
beat up by your spouse. I mean,
the idea that men don't have the
better end of the deal is unbelievably
ridiculous.
When you look at this,
Donald Sterling guy is fucking
shithead that owns the clippers.
He's 82 his girlfriend was
in her twenties and it this,
this,
this possibility only exists for men.
It doesn't exist for women.
There's very few 82 year old women who
have attractive 20 year old boyfriends.
It just doesn't exist. This is very,
very few theory. You're on the watch.
Watch what Madonna does. Um, oh,
it's down the line. Do you know how,
what,
what kind of a monster?
Like a lot of young men would feel like
Madonna was if Madonna was trying to
fuck them.
They're like,
it's repulsive to men and
an idea of a powerful,
attractive man who's in his 50s dating
a 20 year old woman is not alien at all.
But the idea of a powerful woman,
what does it Madonna in
her sixties how old is she?
I think she's 50s but I think
that's what's really, to be honest,
really cool about what she's doing.
But that was just like,
she's just really constantly challenging
those kinds of stereotypes. Well,
I think so by the way. She, I
dunno. I think that she's suddenly,
I think she's got a pretty intelligent
point of view on some of these,
these sort of agenda issues because
she, she really, you know, I mean,
and I think the fact that
people find it uncomfortable,
it's kind of making the point
that we are drinking about,
which is that this is not how it's
supposed to be. Yeah. Well she's,
she doesn't even consider
herself a feminist. She
considers herself a humanist,
which I agree with wholeheartedly.
And this idea of a men's rights,
what's really offensive about it is that,
you know,
they're concentrating entirely on the
ideas and the problems that men face when
I think the only ideas and
promises problems that men face.
The only ones are child custody
and getting robbed in divorces.
Other than that, shut the fuck up.
Yeah. I really do believe that.
I think those are the only two issues.
Other than that, please shut the fuck up.
Because when I hear about a guy who
planning that a 20 year old wife is a,
is mean to a 60 year old rich man,
oh poor baby.
This is what you do. Go Out and
get more 20 year old wives', okay,
you're fucking richest shit and you're
old. What are you gonna live forever,
dummy. He'll go get some prostitutes.
Go do it. It'd be nice to them.
Give them cars.
You know what to do with Donald Sterling
did he got that girl like five Rolls
Royce's and Bentley's and Ferrari's and
shit and it still didn't work out that
you know why it didn't work out.
She didn't want to fuck him.
They don't want to fuck you. You're 80
okay. That is just the law of the land.
That's the way life works.
This is the natural balance of
nature and you know you, you've,
you've figured out a way to inject
influence and power and money and sort of
pervert this whole system.
Yeah.
And when you complain about this
perversion not working out in your favor,
and this is why we need men's
rights, he's go, Oh fucking Christ.
You whiny bitches. You guys
aren't men. You guys are babies.
I think it's just unbelievable that
they're even talking to their babies.
They're babies,
and they're not recognizing the issues
that women do have to deal with.
Women have to deal with
worrying about groups of men.
Women have to deal with worrying about,
if I walk into a parking lot, okay,
and it's at night,
and I see a woman in that parking lot,
I'm not worried about that woman,
but if I was a woman and I walked into
a parking lot and I'm walking to my car
and I see a man and that
man's looking me in the eye,
I have to wonder what kind of a man
that is. I have to think about that.
I have to think about that as a man.
But as a woman,
you really have to think about that.
It's very rare that a man gets robbed
by a woman in a parking lot. Of course,
it can happen, especially if the
woman has a weapon. Of course,
if you're in Russia, she
might rape you. You know this,
this is some stories about Russian women.
You know,
there's some story about she helps him,
mankind captive and forced fed and
Viagra and fuck them for 30 days.
And that's the Russians.
They're crazy.
Some Russian chick might
actually do that to you,
but for the most part it's a nonissue
or statistically speaking to a very,
very, very small percentage
of the population has to
worry about this. For Women,
the amount of women that get sexually
assaulted, the amount of women,
especially like in college, it's
crazy. And colleges, you know,
something like more than one on a 10
women get sexually assaulted in college.
I don't know the exact numbers.
I've read varying reports,
but even 10% it's fucking
really big problem. I agree.
It's a big problem if you're a
woman because men are aggressive,
we're aggressive, we're filled with
testosterone and we need to come.
It's a real problem every day or
balls or building up more, more sperm.
And if you're a shithead and if you were
raised in properly and you don't have
respect for women or the opposite sex
or anyone in general other than yourself
itself, yes, we have problems.
We have problems with that. So,
yeah,
we need accountability as men,
but it would also help if there was places
where people could relieve themselves
and it also help if there was a hand
job place on every corner. I mean,
God Damn Kona, why not? There's
a massage place in every corner.
You drive down the street in La.
If you drive to go to Ventura Boulevard,
drive down the street.
If your back is bothering you,
you can find a massage place.
One a mile,
you'll see a neon light time massage,
Swedish massage this beside you
can go in and get your neck robbed.
Why can't you get your, your balls
rubbed? Why can't you? Why not?
Because we're crazy because we
have these weird ideas about sex.
We have these weird ideas about what
is evil and it's based on the puritan
values of this country was founded on,
which are founded by religious nuts who
were were so cookie that they got in
boats to escape persecution and traveled
across the fucking ocean. I mean,
that's the, the echoes of this ignorance
is still propelling us today. Yeah.
I think the, I dunno, I think that
with all that stuff, the thing,
I've got a lot of sympathy for it,
but I just keep coming back to this thing
about, well, what is the, if you know,
what does it,
are you going to set up a situation where
it's not really a choice that there's
some kind of economic or
other power that's, that's,
that means that Oh, pressure.
That means that, um,
even though you kind of treat it like
a marketplace where everyone's freely
entering into it, is that
really going with the case?
I think that's the question.
I just think you're totally right.
I don't know.
And I'm not suggesting by the way,
the prostitution is going to stop rape,
you know, what I'm suggesting is
that there are real issues with,
with human sexuality and there's real
issues with making things illegal that
shouldn't be illegal. Whether it's
drug use or whether it's sexuality.
I think there's real
issues in suppression.
And I think when you suppress
people from doing things,
whether it's suppressing
them from using marijuana,
suppressing them from
drinking, suppressing them
from wearing certain clothes,
suppressing women from driving,
when you suppress human beings
from things that are illogical,
and I find it illogical
that sex is illegal to sell.
And I'm not saying I want to go
to prostitutes. I don't, I don't,
but I think they should be illegal.
I really do. I think it's nonsense.
I think we live in this weird world where
if something is legal to do for free,
how is it possible that it's illegal to
do for money? It doesn't make any sense.
I see your point of view and I agree with
it wholeheartedly that you do have to
worry about people being sold into this.
That you have to worry about them being
somehow or another compromise by this,
this overwhelming need for, you know, the,
the financial revenue that
can be generated from sex
and that people could be
exploited and that could it be a real
issue with the objectification of women?
It could change the cultural
attitudes about things.
But if you go to countries where
it is legal, that prostitution,
I was just going to say, I think
in Hololens, right? Yeah, they,
they find lower instances of aids,
lower instances of like Jim Jefferies,
he's a buddy of mine who's a standup
comedian from Australia in Australia.
Brothels are illegal.
And he talks about how divorce rates are
way lower in places where brothels or
legal, because the men don't
need to cheat on their wives.
Like some man just give up, they can't,
they can't get sex with their wife.
And he goes, fuck, I'm fucking Outta here.
And they get divorced and they go
through this huge stressful situation in
Australia. You just go
to a brothel, you know?
And Jim was joking around about how his,
his mom and his dad were fighting
and his mom was like, yeah,
and he goes to the brothel every night.
I don't know if you know that or every
Wednesday night. And he goes, oh,
everyone's day. And that
was, that was the punchline.
And I don't think there's
anything wrong with that.
It's whether or not people are being
exploited, that becomes the problem.
But that becomes a problem
with everything. I mean,
if people are being exploited into labor,
if children are being forced to
work in factories at, at young ages,
which they are in other countries and
typically other countries that provide us
with these, these goods that we
so want cell phones, laptops,
all of these different,
I mean how many children
every year scraping minerals
out of the mountains that
they need to come to use to make
electronics. There's a lot of them.
And this is expectation.
This is exploitation that we benefit from.
And I think that we have to
address all forms of that.
But we also have to address ridiculous
laws that don't make any sense.
And anytime you try to control people
and any time you try to suppress ability
to express themselves in any way,
if you don't like it, you know,
whether it's walking topless down the
street, you can do it. If you're a man,
you can't do it.
If you're a woman.
And that's what they're dealing with
in New York City. Now in New York City,
you're allowed to be topless
as a one. Like the, um,
there's some woman who calls herself
the fucking naked cow girl and she's
getting sued by the naked cowboy cause
the naked cowboy is the guy who he wears
underwear and he plays guitar with a
cowboy hat on and he's like this sort of
tourist attraction in New York.
Well women are allowed to be topless now
as well in a lot of places because they
like,
the idea is well why is a man allowed
to have no shirt on but a woman has to
have, it's because you're
saying that breasts are much
more sexual than know when
they're on a woman and that they
need to be, they need to be covered.
And that sort of develops a sort of
inequality in the law that a woman is,
you know,
a woman is a oppressed or a woman is,
I'm subject to law that a man is not.
And that seems to be very
difficult to pass. So you know,
you deal with some situation where
women are allowed to be topless and they
should be. How many guys get arrested
for being Juggalos? Is it zero? I mean,
what was the last time a guy got arrested
for fucking a woman because she paid
them to,
has it ever even happened.
But women get arrested for prostitution
all the God damn time, you know,
totally agree with that. I mean that is
the rather than the people using them.
Yeah. It's just totally, I agree with
that. I think that when there's all I,
you're right that there's so many kinds
of weird things about sex and, and,
and how that kind of plays out when you
think about sort of social issues and
stuff like that. And I think one of the
biggest things that's going on is, um,
the way that kind of that kind
of the sort of sexualization of,
of,
you know,
like public space and the w they'll
kind of world around us is like really
influencing more, more children.
I think that they're kind of,
it's getting younger and younger kids
are being exposed to kind of sexualized
stuff.
Um,
that is a real problem cause it's changing
their expectation and what sex is.
And there's lots of studies now
showing how the, you know, like kids,
sexual behavior is really different.
You know,
boys sort of viewing porn and violent
porn at much earlier age thinking that
that's how you behave,
treating women really badly,
women thinking of themselves
as sexual objects more.
I think there's a lot of kind of quite
deep problems that are coming out and
we'll see in the years ahead from
the way that that is just, you know,
like sexual images and content is just
becoming much more widely available for
younger kids.
That's a really good point because it's
so prevalent and it's so uniquely new.
The ability to download
porn on his cell phone.
So essentially if your child
is 12 and they have an iPhone,
you send them off to school,
they're watching people, fuck yeah,
I'm mean they're Gunna,
that's fine.
There's no way you're going to stop
them if that phone has internet data,
if it has internet access.
So those kids are going to look at images
if they have somehow or another summit,
some access to an iPad or a laptop or
something that's connected to Wifi.
If it's not blocked through some sort of
a complicated filter that they probably
know how to dismantle than you do,
they're going to see sex.
They're going to see sex in
a way that we never saw sex.
And I have this joke in my act that is
a true story about when I was 11 years
old, me and a couple of my friends found
a magazine in the woods that was a foot
fetish magazines. And uh, we,
it took us like a few minutes
to realize what was going on.
We were looking at this magazine
because it was really confusing.
You thought it was like as a
podiatry today or something? No, no,
we thought it was a porn magazine for
sure. Obviously that was the intent that,
yeah. Okay. Well we, we were in
the woods. All right. And um,
I don't know if you've ever found
pornographic magazines in the woods.
Do you ever find them a hustler or in
house? In the woods. In the woods, right?
Yeah. And the puck in the look. Yeah.
But it's always like some poor bastard
who's hiding his urges. It's a class,
it's a rite of passage,
you know,
I think that it's very important everyone
had that experience international.
Yeah. Because for me it was in
Florida and for you it was in England.
It's amazing, right? The foot
thing. That is exactly unexpected.
So what the point was that we found these,
this bag that had these magazines in
it and we're going through this one
magazine and it took us like many
pages in to my, my friend goes,
dude, this shit is all just dicks and
feet. Like that's sad. And we were,
and to this day I,
I laugh thinking about my friend saying
that and that we were stunned and
confused. Well we were just looking
at a magazine and we were 11,
you know,
today kids get to watch actual sex
and apparently this sexual activity of
children is changing.
Like someone did some study recently
that showed this massive increase in anal
sex amongst children under
18 years of age. It's really,
I think it's a really big deal.
I really do. And, and it's,
and it's the sexual activities changing.
It's the kind of relationship between,
um, men and women, boys and
girls, you know, that is
changing. And the coal kind of,
um, we talked about early in terms of,
you know, women's rights and men's rights.
And I think that that, you know,
the expectations of how to behave,
how to treat women and women's
own sense or young women,
their own sense of themselves
as primarily being about that,
you know, sexual, sexual persona. I think
that's all really a concern. You know,
it's actually setting back some of the
kind of progress that's been made in
terms of women women's equality.
I agree.
But I think hopefully at least,
cause I'm, I'm the eternal optimist.
I think it's temporary and I think
that ultimately it's all gonna even out
because I think that what people are
doing is they're looking at these things
like if, if, if women are engaging
in these sexual activities, uh,
at a much earlier age,
they're looking at it,
it's like this is something
that they need to do
to become more attractive to men
because this is what they've seen.
They've seen this.
My thought on all of this is that
we're going to reach a point within our
lifetimes probably within the next few
decades where we're going to be able to
read each other's minds. I think.
I think it's inevitable, you know,
over your house. Actually,
it was the first time I ever
tried Google glass, right?
And we were putting this thing
on and scanning it and you know,
and googling things and looking at
navigation screens in front of my eye
thinking, man, Shit's going to
get really fucking weird soon.
I think we're going to be able to
read each other's minds. I think this,
this whole dance that we do,
do you like me? Do I like you?
You know who I'm going to play hard
to get. I'm going to fucking do this.
I'm going to be the girl that takes it
in the ass and all the boys going to like
me. You know? I think all that
nonsense, I think it's gonna.
It's going to become far more complex,
the human interactions because it's going
to become far more complex because our
concept of of secrets is
going to go out the window.
That's really interesting
actually. I don't think
there's going to exist anymore.
I think if you look at the trend,
what is the trend?
The trend is that information is easier
to access now than ever before and it
becomes easier to access and easier to
access and to the point where you can ask
your phone questions with your voice,
you press a button,
you know who is Steve Hilton but it
Steve Hilton is a ball ball, ball ball,
ball ball and it gives you the information
but that's just one step and it's not
going to stop there. It's not halting.
It's exponentially increasing. So what is,
what's the trend?
The trend is dissolving boundaries
between people and information.
That information includes
information in your own mind.
That information includes,
there's going to be a much more effective
interface that looking at a screen and
asking a screen of question,
the interface is going to be
somehow or another a neural implant,
something that you inject into
someone's body like nanobots. It's good.
There's going to be some weird sort
of an interface and when that happens
they're going to come up with
a better one a year later.
It's going to be a more invasive one
or more and then we're going to have to
come to some sort of an agreement where
we were going to say, hey, listen,
in order for human, the human race to a
established an enlightened perspective,
we're all going to have to look into
each other's heads and we're all going to
have to be able to read each other's
minds and find out how we think and feel
and so there'll be no more
mystery in this world.
There'd be no more romance novels,
there'll be no more. There's no,
there'll be unnecessary is not going to
be any romance is going to be this weird
hive mind thing going on and it's
going to happen within a hundred years.
And it's good. I think that's
incredibly interesting and the,
the way that that will change so many
things. If, if people just say, you know,
if that comes to pass and people can
just know what the other person thinking,
think about what it used to be like
before language is established.
People used to grunt and point and kind
of try to figure out what the other
person wanted. I mean, we're essentially
monkey people. What did we do? We've,
we've figured something out.
We got to this point and now you
compare your life today to that point.
Like I
was in a conversation
with a friend and um,
we have another friend that is like
a, he's becoming a prepper, you know,
like a,
he's fucking setting up his house for
solar water and collecting rainwater or
solar, uh, solar power and connecting,
collecting rain water and growing his
own fruits and vegetables and doing so in
this fear that society
was going to collapse.
And my friend Jimmy was like,
if society collapses,
you don't want to live man. Like you
don't want to be that one fucking God.
It's got all the food and you're,
you know,
standing on your porch with a rifle and
you're all taking turns waiting for the
zombies to come over the hill.
You know,
sounding the horns and alerting the
people that the barbarians have arrived.
You don't want to do that and you
don't want to go back to those days.
You just don't.
And I think that we,
we don't want to go back to the days
of no language and we're not going to,
going to want to go back to the days of,
of secrets.
We're not going to want to once,
once the no secret thing happens and
people just get this kind of understanding
of what it is to be a human being.
Nice. That it's universal. Yeah.
It reminds me is that there's this,
um, what going on at Stanford,
they have a virtual reality
lab and they're looking at
how virtual reality could
change the way people think about other
people about other issues. You know,
there's, there's one experiment
that doing where I'll go pro,
I'm just trying to get
it right where they,
I think they put you as
like in a forest situation,
you think you're in a forest and they,
and then they measure some nature and
some example of nature and then they see
how they really give you a deep experience
of that through virtual reality.
And then they look at your behavior in
the next week after that to see if you're
more conscious of that.
You recycle more, you,
you change your behavior because of
this is completely false experience.
You've had to give you this
virtual reality experience and,
and that's what they're researching
and all sorts of other ways.
And I think it's showing that it does
and you can actually influence someone's
behavior by giving them the sense of
another world. Yeah. And that's again,
just in its infancy. You know, the,
the virtual reality stuff is
just getting going and, um,
and I just think it's
interesting all these things,
how they will affect so many aspects of
how we relate to each other and think
about these issues that the moment it
just so kind of superficially dealt with,
it's going to get really squirrely.
Wouldn't that artificial
realities indistinguishable
from the reality that we're
experiencing right now? Cause
that's coming to, you know,
that's what the whole
simulation theory is, uh, is,
is based upon how this idea that one day
we're going to get to a point where you
can't tell whether or not we live in
a computer or we live in the material
carbon based flesh world.
And if that's the case,
how do we know that we haven't
already gotten to that point.
How do we know that we're not in a
computer right now and we're thinking that
we're experiencing this reality but it's
not, it's not really happening. It's,
we're just a part of a program
and that it's so good that you
just, you can't, you think you really are
Steve Hilton if you're not Steve Hilton.
And he said, you know the
truth Joe, he had set out,
the thing is that when this kind of
gets to a point where I just kind of,
I can't handle it anymore. My brain
cannot literally cope with, uh,
thinking about some of this stuff.
I remember a friend of mine repeatedly
trying to explain to me like quantum
physics and quantum things and I
just literally can't understand it.
Yeah. The quantum stuff is
hard, really hard. I have a,
I had this notion of,
you know,
alternate realities and things
going on at the same time.
I just can't get my head around it.
It's almost impossible to do.
It's,
it's really like when you start
getting into quantum stuff,
I don't even think they understand it.
I mean they,
they understand that in terms
of these theoretical concepts,
but it's so abstract and a lot of ways
when you're dealing with things like when
they start talking about
subatomic particles and they
started talking about the
things that they actually do know, like
the things that you actually can measure,
you can observe. Yeah, like
particles in super position,
meaning they're in movement and still
at the same time when they're talking
about things blinking
in and out of existence,
they go away and they don't know where
they went and then they come back with
just that alone. The measurable stuff
is so crazy that the lowest point,
not the lowest, but the smallest
measurable point of reality,
which is this, these, these quantum
ideas, the world's made of magic,
things appear and disappear. Things are
still in their moving at the same time.
They're here and they're there.
They're in two different places at the
same time and they can take particles and
they can move them across the world and
it, when they interact with each other,
they interact with each other faster
than you can count faster than you can
measure.
They interact with each other like
instantaneously faster than the,
in any kind of communication that we
could have between these particles,
given the amount of distances in
between them, the speed of light,
the speed of sound, they, they,
they're instantaneously
interacting with each other.
Now they're figuring out a way how
to send particles through time.
They're figuring out ways
to send particles through
time to actually time travel
with particles.
And so all this stuff that they're
doing right now is just one step on this
never ending quest for
technological innovation.
There's never ending quest where people
are trying to satisfy their curiosity.
They're not going to stop.
They're never gonna stop if we don't
get hit by an asteroid if we don't get,
I think that's right
then that's, you know, and you get all
these good things coming from that. Yeah.
Along the way. I mean,
I don't understand it,
but eventually it leads to things
that we all can use and um,
and deal with. A lot of those things
are really good. I don't think that,
I think one thing I would say about all
this stuff is that generally speaking,
we are not critical enough of
the technological advances.
I think that a lot of them
are obviously in improvements.
You know, if you think
about just technology going
back many years, you know,
the way that,
I don't know,
like labor saving devices in the home
completely sort of freed women from
through the drudgery and the horrific
kind of washing machine, all that stuff.
That was just kind of such a terrible
experience and that's all a fantastic sort
of simple example of technology being
really transformational in a positive way.
And I think generally that's
probably true of technology.
It's usually an improvement,
but I do think that we have this kind
of attitude of assuming it's good and
just, and not really questioning
it. Do we really want that?
I think that doesn't happen enough
often. The answer will be, yeah, we do.
That's great. Fantastic. Bring it on.
But I don't think we stop
enough to ask the question.
And I think that the scientists
and the people doing this stuff,
they don't really think about that.
They just,
they want to do it because they can.
And it's as exactly as you said,
it's this curiosity like let's just go
further because that's a human instinct.
It's like when Oppenheimer
built the nuclear bomb,
I mean that should that really have
been done? Well the, you know, the,
the argument, the intelligent
argument is if they didn't do it,
the Nazis would have done it.
So yes,
it's important that the allied
forces developed at first.
But I think that that's the job of,
I think there's all sorts of roles that
are played in a society and there's the,
the innovator and there's the scientists,
there's the people that are constantly
pushing the boundaries of technology.
And then there's the, the social
engineers who step back and go, okay,
let's look at the repercussions of this
and how do we mitigate the negative
aspects of it?
How do we figure out how to integrate
these ideas into society and use them to
enhance society and what is being
done to sort of manage that.
And what is being done to to
minimize the negative impact.
Yeah, that is a good way of putting
it that that different functions.
There's just a constant,
there's no one thing that's awesome.
There's things that are awesome and then
there's repercussions that are like,
yeah, but then there's this, well
there's that, but then there's this,
this part of it that we're not really
comfortable with and there's this sort of
dance that we do as we build society and
as society continues to grow and expand
and our ability to do things changes
our ability to access information,
our ability to accomplish goals,
our ability to transmit ideas is so much
quicker and faster and there's these
repercussions to that
that were before this.
This Day and age we're really unexplored
because they weren't available,
so we don't really know the long term
repercussions of children being able to
access porn because they
really didn't have it. Yes,
it's new. We've never done it.
What that leads to weird world.
Weird world. Steve Hilton,
strange times. Is it good, good summary.
That's why you tooth and claw resisted.
I done it, and this is definitely
going back in there, but the,
the way I agreed to it was like,
if I'm away,
I need a fund that they
can get hold of me.
Yeah, that's it. That's it. And then
you could shut it off occasionally,
but to give it to very few people,
you have to have a burner phone.
Do you have to have a phone?
Do you give to people that could possibly
be annoying so that any given time it
fell into the ocean, you'd
be like, Eh, whatever. What
that fucking phone, you know,
and then have a phone that you only give
to your family and your close friends.
Yeah.
Well one of the things is that
really puts me off. I just can't,
there's something about my kind of
useless to the fat, stubby fingers.
I just hopelessness with touchscreens.
That's all you can get. It's touchscreen.
So when we were in Hawaii,
you through your fucking Ipod at your
computer and fucked up the screen,
you were so frustrated.
Steve got, uh, you know,
I have a regular iPod with
the click wheel. The wheel.
I liked that. I liked that.
But the, the new ones,
the iPod touches, I don't, I don't find
them as, they're not as easy to use.
And I'm at the gym. I find them to
be frustrating, you know, but you,
you got ahold of one of those because
you couldn't get your regular iPad.
You got so mad he threw it at your
fucking computer. That mark is,
that reminds me of my tech.
No rage every single day.
But you're not a rageful guy,
which is so crazy cause you're normally
the last person I would expect to get
violent and throw something and get crazy.
But it was an iPod that did it to you.
I know it was weird,
but I do with technology as people who
know me and work with me will testify.
You've very Unabomber ask and that
way. Oh Gosh. Okay. I better watch it.
There's a,
a,
a great documentary on the Unabomber
and how he became who he is.
I don't want to get into it cause
I've talked about on the show before,
but it's called the net and it's a,
I think it's German.
I forget what contributes
available with subtitles.
But basically he was a part of the LSD
studies at Harvard. They cooked his brain.
That's Ted Kaczynski.
Ted Cause Yeah. Yeah.
And he was turned in by his own brother,
his own brother recognize the
writing and the manifesto.
And he realized that his
brother had gone insane.
It's like I think this is probably
my brother that's doing this. Wow.
Cause I wasn't here then, but that was
a, so I don't have a sense of it being,
I know that know what happened,
but I don't get a sense
of what a big deal it was.
It was scary for a lot of people
in America when that happened.
What was scary for a lot of people
also because of who he was attacking,
that he was attacking people that
were technological innovators,
whose attacking people that were involved
in the distribution of technology.
And he believed that and in a lot of
ways correctly believed that there was
something going on right now where
people were creating technology and this
technology would eventually do bad
things to the human race and to the
biological existence that we
currently exist in. You know, this,
this sort of like established way of
being and living that we consider being,
you know,
inherent to being a human being.
And he felt like these people were the
enemies of humanity because they were
fostering technology and creating items
where they know that that was what was
behind all that.
He went too far ahead.
He got wacky instead of living in the
moment and dealing with the moment.
He just saw this,
this attack by the biological humans or
on the biological humans by technology,
which essentially I kind
of see his point in a way.
I don't see his point as far as like
attacking people that are creating
technology,
but if you really extrapolate where we
are right now and where we're going,
this symbiotic relationship that we have
with technology where people are afraid
to leave their phones behind the phones
will eventually become Google glass.
Google glass would become an implant. An
implant will become, well, you know Steve,
he's got good news and bad news.
The good news is you have a year to live.
Okay? The, the bad news
is you have cancer.
The good news is we have an artificial
body that we have created that we're
going to put your body into.
The bad news is it lasts forever.
So we're going to take, or is it the
good news? You know, this is what it is,
is a new world that we're living in where
we're going to have weird choices that
never existed before and a lot of the
people that are involved in Google,
they hired Kurzweil, Ray
Kurzweil, who is the proponent,
the number one proponent of this sort of
trends in dental moment where we become
one with computers where we become one
either with some sort of a computer
interface or we download our consciousness
and do an artificial body or we
figure out a way to exist in some sort
of a virtual reality that is eternal and
there's, that's a lot of people feel
like that's where things are going to go.
Give us the science fiction
really not fixed. You know,
it's definitely happening. Yeah.
The one I talked to a friend
of mine about this quite a bit,
which is if you think about,
I'm just interested that
there, I got the unit on it.
That's an extreme example and I wasn't,
I didn't realize that it was
so focused on technology, but there
isn't really a, people like it.
Generally speaking,
there isn't really a movement that's sort
of anti technology movement that not,
certainly not that I'm aware of. If
you think back to, you know, the, um,
I can remember exactly when it was,
but when you had this sort of industrial
revolution and the Luddites, you know,
smashing up machines that were,
you know,
taking jobs away from people
and then their view really
kind of damaging society.
There's, that was a, it's got quite a
big movement. Okay. Didn't get anywhere.
And then history sort
of made them irrelevant,
but there was a movement with their
name and an organization that did stuff.
What did they, what was there? There are,
I think there's specifically, it was
the, the new equipment, like the weaving,
you know,
during the industrial
revolution in England and the
machines that were now being
used to do the work that had been done by
people and they, they objected to that.
Not Incredible. And they would literally
physically smash up the machines.
That was,
I think one of the things they did.
And I'm sure there's people with a better
study of history that can give you a
better picture, but that was,
they'll call the Luddites,
I think named after the
person that set the ma,
someone called Lud, I think. Um, uh,
and I don't know how big it was,
but it isn't as big enough
that it's something we still
know about and it's part
of the history of that, of that era.
And there's nothing like that now.
Not,
not to my knowledge where you,
you don't have people going out and
smashing up cell phone towers. No.
Make a point about technology. Well,
I think it's what we were saying.
Other people like it,
you know,
it's kind of helps them in their lives
and they like it for the most part. Yeah.
I mean, there's a lot of benefits.
There's a lot of benefits to technology,
but I think it's what we
were talking about earlier,
that maybe back then they didn't have
enough information to draw upon and they
saw it as being this direct
threat to their livelihood.
And I think that was a big part of
it. And I think today we're, we're,
we're sort of forced into this realization
that it's neither good nor bad,
but rather something that needs to be
managed and there's good aspects to it and
then there's negative aspects to it and
ultimately you have to figure out what
outweighs what and how to lean it towards
the positive and how to manage it in a
way that it goes towards the positive.
And I think that's the case when we were
talking about with children watching
television, you know, I know
there's the Waldorf School, um,
my oldest daughter was in the Waldorf
school system for awhile and it's a lot of
wackiness to that. Like they
didn't believe in any technology.
They didn't believe in, in the
video games. But is it had been,
they've proven that video games
can enhance cognitive function.
Then the neural pathways that are
created by stimulating video games can
actually there they mimic the
games like chess, you know,
like it was problem solving games,
games that stimulate the imagination
and creativity like they exist.
Video Games can be used
in that same function.
This idea that all video games are bad.
And then I found out that the guy who
founded this whole Waldorf system was that
Cham Miller.
He was a channeler like I,
I'm getting a voice. There's a spirit
who's talking to me about like, Oh,
you fuck head guide to, is
that our oldest son? You know,
you know, he's in, um, uh,
the same system. Yeah. That
system has created by Kooks.
Unfortunately,
it's wonderful system and a lot of
ways the school that my kid was at,
it was great, but the reality is
that it's founded by fuckheads,
you know, founded by Christ. People that
I'm definitely gonna look into that.
Chandler. Yeah, we'll, we'll talk,
I'll tell you the whole deal
when we get off the air.
I'll tell ya the conversations that I
had with these fucking people where I'm
like, what, what, what, what
would channeler it's, you know,
there's a lot of evidence that there's
Chandler's no, there's not actually,
there's none. There's zero evidence that
anybody's ever been fucking channeler.
You know, I have a friend who he loves to
believe in stupid shit and uh, he just,
he's not a good critical thinker.
He's a great guy,
but he's not a good critical thinker.
He's the first one that comes to me
with a fucking ghost story, you know?
And he came to me with this
psychic thing which says,
God knew all about my grandmother, man.
The guy was real, the guy's legit. I go,
do you know about your
grandmother? He goes, yeah, I go.
So the guy told you some shit you already
knew what kind of fucking uses that.
You're just talking to some guy who's,
you're playing games.
You played the trivia game,
playing a trivia game about things you
already know about your own family.
This is a ridiculous, like what kind of
a question did he ask you? Like, Hey,
leading questions that you answered in
some way that he was able to concoct the
story of your life. And people want
to find that these things are correct.
They want to find that someone is,
but there's almost no evidence whatsoever
that anybody has a functional psychic
energy and method that is reproducible.
And it doesn't mean that I don't believe
in the potential for psychic psychic
powers. Cause I think there's some
weird connection with human beings.
It's probably emerging much
like a lot of our senses emerge.
I think there's, there's weird senses
that are emerging with human beings.
Like for instance, they've
statistically shown in, in a,
in a way that's measurable that people
can tell when people are looking at the
back of their head.
Yeah.
You could tell in someone's looking at
someone's looking behind you at you that
the people could sense it in a way
that is more measurable than chance.
So I think there's
probably something there.
This is probably something when
you think about someone in,
they call you and then
it happens, let's, I've,
I've thought about people and all of
sudden I get an email from them out of the
blue.
I haven't talked to them a years and all
of a sudden I'd be a person that was,
that popped into my mind. Like, wow,
I wonder what that guy's up to. Boom.
We get an email from, hey man,
what's up? Like, wow, what is that?
Is that a weird sort of a distant
connection that will eventually one day be
much more strong? I Dunno. I Dunno.
But I know that a fucking
channeler starting a school
that tells you not to use
cell phones and don't watch TV. That
guy's a silly pitch. This is ridiculous.
It doesn't make any sense. You
know, I think, I think you're right.
The anything that's really extreme is
it's just not going to be right. I think.
And they, and so we definitely
don't implement the extreme version.
Of course they recommend that's
not quite right with all things.
Even with reading, you can't read
all day, every day, go outside,
go for a walk, go ride a bike,
go do something, get out.
You got to get out. You've
got to move. You've got to,
and I think that that's the
case with all human experiences.
I mean if you're a person who was a,
there was a thing recently that they, um,
they,
the uh,
thing that they did about sex and about
porn and that people who watch porn,
they,
they actually have less brain matter.
They have less matter in their brain.
People that are obsessed with porn
and you know, when you think about it,
it's probably because the,
whatever they're doing,
whatever part of their
brain they're stimulating,
they're constantly focused on that and
all the other shit about wondering about
existential questions. The, the,
the, the purpose of man, the, the,
the idea of infinity,
all these weird questions that normally
bounce around inside a person's brain,
they're completely nonexistent because
you're just trying to find the next
person at jerk off to your,
just put you back at that guy the other
week that came out in the government,
which gives, you see, he was in the
environmental protection agency I think,
and he was watching, he was,
he was, he lost his job.
He's watching porn like I think six
hours a day or in the office in the
government is going on
that that's even possible.
Well, people are listening to this
podcast in their office, guaranteed.
They shouldn't be. It should be working.
If it's six hours a day watching porn,
maybe they should be. That's like,
you know, yeah, it's ridiculous.
But they're EPA,
EPA employee downloaded 7,000 files of
porn at work and watched him two to six
hours a day.
Well,
I don't think that guy was doing a
good job of protecting the environment.
I'll say I'd fucking freak.
I'm not surprised if you give people
the freedom to move around like that.
That's what they wind up
doing. People are nuts, man.
He give people the freedom to just do
whatever the fuck they want. You know?
A lot of times they do things
they're just trying to smart. Yes.
That's just the way human beings are.
Especially if you give them,
it's like we were talking about as far
as professors or police officers or
anybody in some sort of an ultimate
position where they don't have enough
supervision,
they don't have enough.
Just they have too much influence
over others and they don't have enough
oversight.
We wind up being this fucking guy.
I supposed to be paying attention to our
drinking water and just beaten off all
day.
You know?
And then there's also a job thing too.
It's like how many,
how many jobs you really should there
be for the environmental protection
protection agency and how many people
do they really need to do those jobs if
this guy can.
But that's exactly what is he doing there?
Well we know what he's doing there.
What's the, if this guy can speak to,
if this guy can work in the EPA and he
could still like hold down that job and
he's beaten off six hours a
day and this was for years.
It wasn't like just he went nuts and just
one week for whatever reason went for
it.
It was like for years,
I wonder how many people are listening
to this podcast right now that are like,
fuck, that's me. I want to get busted.
If you're in an office and like,
especially if your computer is facing
like you and you're looking at the door so
you get a clean shot at anybody walking
in, you know for men, men are freaks.
You give a guy the opportunity
to just beat off in his office.
A lot of times dudes are
going to take it up, you know,
environmental protection agency, Jesus
Christ. What a weird world we live in.
Where that's an issue. You imagine if
like, it was back in the day where a,
you know,
a guy who was assigned to work for city
water department in the 1930s they found
7,000 pornography books in
his office. I'm like, frank,
what the fuck are you doing man?
Like getting crazy with all this reading.
I think in a lot of ways what we're
dealing with when it comes to pornography,
when it becomes to the Internet,
when it,
when it comes to just technology itself,
is we're,
we're dealing with these things that
have influence over people in a way that
were not designed to process. You know,
we're not designed to process movies.
A giant screen where explosions and
space ships and all the stuff that's not
real, but we're seeing it in a way that's
much more impactful than real life.
We're seeing it right in front of us.
Yeah. You know, I think that that,
that fucks with people's heads.
You know, I think that pornography,
the ability to at any time you want just
go online and watch people have sex,
like the, you know, that you could do
that and it's at your little fingertips.
Especially if you're like
sexually starved. You know,
if you're like you really want sex
and you can't get it and you know,
I could watch it right now. I'm going to
watch sex real quick. Oh, margin sucks.
That's a weird thing with human beings.
So weird thing that we've sort of
painted ourselves into this corner.
We have all this technology
as we're talking about before.
It's like we have access to it
and it's all, it's about managing.
It really did. This next
thing is also, you know,
reminds us that we're just animals
really because you've got, I remember,
you know, really struck my
kids love nature programs.
You Watch these nature programs and
basically that are about sex and eating.
That's what happens. That's what happens
in nature. That's what will this out.
That's the majority of the scenes that
you see. Yeah, that is what it is.
And so we just, um, and that sense
animals, well, we certainly are.
And that makes the same.
It's, it's, it's, it's not,
I don't think we should be surprised
that it's such a dominant part of,
of life. No, no. We definitely
shouldn't be surprised.
But we're also much more
complex than the average animal.
That's where things get really weird.
Where things get really weird is that yes,
we are animals,
but we are also animals with computers.
We're also animals that are
aware that we're animals.
So we have to think about our actions.
We're self aware,
we're aware of the influence
that others have on us,
and we're constantly expanding
that influence. You know,
so we're not just animals,
we're animals with computers
that may become part of machines.
That's the thing that
freaks me out the most.
It's a symbiotic connection
that human beings have.
The technology and the potential for
developing artificial technology or
artificial life. I think that we,
we give birth to that. I mean,
Marshall Mcluhan once said that human
beings are the sex organs and the machine
world.
And I always wonder if we're not some
strange caterpillar that becomes a
butterfly that has no idea
what the fuck it's doing,
and we're making some sort
of a technological cocoon
thinking that we're just
doing my thing running around and
looking at porn. No, you know,
you're a part of this gigantic machine
that's processing and pushing for the
innovation of technology and
the innovation of technology
will eventually give
birth to a life form.
They're constantly working on
trying to map out the human mind,
duplicate the functions
of the human bought mine.
It's some sort of a synthetic process
and we're not anywhere close right now,
but the way technology itself.
Exactly. Yeah. It's, it's,
it feels unlikely that that's not
going to happen. Yeah. I heard this,
I read this article by this really
grumpy fuck who's an interesting guy.
He's a smart guy,
but he's also just a probably a lonely
shithead and he was mocking Ray Kurtzweil
how ray Kurzweil knows nothing about the
human mind and he was talking about the
complicated functions of the human mind
and the way the human mind processes
proteins and that this
is barely understood,
but what I read from this
and what I got out of this,
it's like I don't think this
guy understands that it's
the biological functions
are not going to matter if they can be,
if these biological functions can be
completely irrelevant because they've
figured out some sort of an artificial
way to duplicate all of the exact same
synapse firing mechanisms like without
all the biological functions of the
processing of the proteins,
the interacting with the hormones
and human neurotransmitter's.
All that stuff is great
if you're using a body,
but this guy was so hung up on the fact
that Kurzweil's wrong because we don't
understand how the human body works,
but no, no, he's not because he's just,
you're just talking about bodies.
Yeah, bodies are super complicated.
We haven't totally figured it out yet,
but we might not have to.
If we could figure out a way to do
all the things that the body does,
but do it with a computer or do with
technology or do with some sort of quantum
computer,
some sort of quantum computer that's
contained in an artificial body that can
completely replicate the functions of
consciousness, the functions of, of,
of emotions, of interaction,
of curiosity, of creativity.
If you can develop an artificial
computer that's creative, you're not,
it doesn't matter what Luton Ising
hormones and all this shit that you're
bitching about. Your just bitching
because you're showing your intelligence,
you're trying to show
people how smart yard,
like criticizing a known genius
cause you're not a known genius.
I mean that's essentially
what you're doing. Yeah.
And it seems to just super efficient. I
know nothing about it, but the, the, the,
the body parts of it feels like they, you
know, there's a ton of progress, right,
that they sort of volume mechanics and
robotics is that that is easy compared to
the brain. Yeah. Yeah. No, I agree.
It is the what's what they do know about
the mind and they do know about the
body is comparatively rudimentary.
When you think about what
we know about a clock,
we know everything about a clock.
You know,
you could buy a switch wa a Swiss swatch
and there's a man out there that knows
every single function of that watch,
knows how it interacts,
knows exactly what's going
on. Tick Tock, tick tock.
We don't know that about the body
yet. You're right. You're correct.
But we're not going to have to,
we're not going to have to because
they're going to come out with some shit
that's way better than a body.
They're going to come out with some
shit that's way stronger than a mind and
it's going to be artificial and one day
it's going to go hello and you're going
to go, oh shit. And why exactly are you
guys living like this? And you're like,
oh, well, I don't know. Just kind of
going on momentum. We just, how we do it.
I don't think this is the best way to
go about this. I don't think so either.
I have a better idea.
Oh Great.
And then this fucking thing is gonna take
over and then we're going to have real
problems and he's going to
really reform our campaign.
Finance laws are going to have any
voting and read each other's minds.
It's not going to be any voting.
We're going to know what's important
and what's not. There was a guy once,
and I've brought this up before,
but it's important to know,
there was a guy that we talked about
in the podcast who had been bitten by a
shark and the shark had taken his arm
and taking his leg and he had this carbon
arm and he was moving his fingers around
him and he was standing there talking
with this fake arm is fake
leg about how great it is.
A technology is provided him
with a way to still be moot,
mobile and functional even though
he'd been attacked by a shark.
And I was sitting there and I was
thinking, wow, this is fascinating.
This guy's like kind of a Cyborg. Um, what
we see as a man with an artificial arm.
And the story was about how well they
had created this arm to the point where
this guy was living a totally
normal life and you know,
was functional and mobile and can take
care of himself even though his arm had
been bitten off by a monster.
And then I thought about, well,
what if it was both legs? Okay? And
then they figured out our official legs,
who would say no to that?
Nobody give him some artificial legs.
Now you can move around. Okay, what if it
was his whole body would say, listen man,
we're going to take your head. We're
going to stick it on a robot bought it,
but you're still going to be you. Oh,
okay. All right, I'll take it. Okay,
we're sticking your head on a robot
body, but listen, we got a problem.
The robot body's rejecting your brain,
but we found an artificial brain
that works just like your brain.
We're going to download your
consciousness to this artificial brain.
You won't even know the difference. Okay,
well then who are you and what are you?
What are you?
Are you a person still?
If you are your thoughts and
your personality and your
memories downloaded into
some creation,
some sort of a new thing that they've
done that mimics all the functions of the
human mind without any of the
biological limitations. What are you,
yeah,
I remembered that.
It's so funny you talking about that
because it reminds me years ago when I was
doing my interviews to,
to go to Oxford University and they'll
have an interview with the philosophy
professor and he gave me this scenario,
which I now know is a
famous philosophical thing.
It's called the experience
machine. And this, this,
this construct very much like
what you're talking about,
which is like if we could put you in a
machine that gave you all the experiences
of a fantastic life,
but it would be a machine doing it,
would you choose to do it? And I
remember saying, um, no, that's,
I wouldn't want to do that because I'd
feel want to have really done it myself.
And if you're just in an machine
that's not the same thing. Oh,
but what if the machine made you feel
like that you've had and you've been on an
egg or whatever?
I said there was some kind of comeback
and in the end I just remember getting
really frustrated.
So I don't know.
That's why I want to come and learn about
philosophy so I can figure this stuff
out. But I have no idea. I kind of lost
my temper. I never did figure it out.
They just throw your phone out the way
before the phone era. But it was just,
it, there comes a point when I
just find it really hard to, to um,
to as or even go very far with this
and I just think, oh well whatever,
let's just sort of get on
with practical life today.
Well it's essentially, it's the Dunbar's
number of philosophical discussion.
Our minds are limited in our ability
to sort of take these ideas in there.
We don't have the capacity
to, to, to extrapolate. It's,
it's too much.
So this,
this concept of recreating reality
in an indistinguishable manner.
It's too weird.
It's too,
but I think it's something we better
start talking about cause it's common.
Yeah. And I, I w you know,
I'm really happy that you are and I
think it's really important that other
people are,
I'm just saying I'm not,
it's way more important than other people
are doing it than me in the hierarchy.
You know a lot more about it than I do.
And you've read more about it than
I have. And um, I just think, yeah,
it's really important that,
that generally we talk about it and keep,
you know,
a really strong sense of awareness of
how these things might change stuff.
And a lot of the time it will be
for the better and that's great.
But we should just talk about it.
Well I had the opportunity to talk to
Kurzweil for an hour and a half and I sat
down and interviewed him
about these things and it
was really fascinating and we
had a great conversation.
But this guy is not thinking
about negatives at all.
All He's thinking of is Gung Ho,
right?
Full blast pedal to the metal.
He mean he's taking like he takes giant
bags of supplements every day cause he's
an older man.
He's just trying to keep his biology
alive long enough to see this,
this new birth of technology
and when it gets really crazy.
What he's trying to do also is he's trying
to make his father come back to life.
His father died when he was young and he
believes that if they figure out a way
to recreate a person from memories,
from just the,
the knowledge of who this person was,
images that you're going to be able to
recreate this guy and some sort of an
artificial form. I mean it's one of
the things he's discussed this, this,
he wants to see his father again and
the idea that he can recreate as father
technologically from men,
from all sorts of different
things, from memory, from all the,
the data that you knows
from recorded stuff in.
One of the most fascinating concepts that
that I've ever heard when it comes to
the Incruse increasing power of computing
is that they're going to get to a 0.1
day.
If computers continue to accelerate,
they're going to get to a 0.1 day where
they can take into account all the
positions of all the objects
and all the things that are,
that exist all over the world as data
and from them extrapolate where things
will be and where things were so
by where things were, meaning,
knowing everything in this room
where it's at in this position,
they'll be able to figure out
how it all got here, who moved.
Jamie moved this over there and Brian
picked that up and turn it on and they'll,
they'll literally be able
to calculate the past.
There'll be able to buy what we have here
by everything we have here and what we
know. There'll be able to
calculate the actions of the past
madness. We're running out of time. That's
what, yeah, he's holding his hand up.
Okay. Well on the computer they hit grade
cause at this point I'm just like, okay,
that's madness. It is. I don't understand
it. They'll be able to look at it.
The ground itself, look at the,
the content of the dirt, the,
the pollution in the ocean.
The carbon in the air,
the distance between these two trees and
the amount of pencils that are on your
desk and they'll be able to figure out
the past because computers will be so far
advanced.
It just reminds me of that line.
I can remember which woody Allen film
where someone's said, how does he,
how he lost his parents. How
does the TV work? I don't,
what do I know about the
don't have the TV was,
I can't even figure out how the can up
and it works. Yeah. I just think like,
you know the TV baffles me that stuff,
you know?
Yeah. Well it should. It should. And it's,
it's only gonna get
more and more baffling.
We're stuck with these dumb monkey
brains. Yes. That's the problem where the,
the dumb monkeys that are sitting around
here waiting for things to change and
when things do change,
we will be just as weird as
some Australia pithiness.
If you put them in a time machine from
a million years ago and threw him into
the fucking Burbank Mall,
this thing would be running around going,
what the fuck guys?
And this because things change
because things grow and things evolve,
including humans.
We're just along for the ride.
So I think the real key to human beings,
and it's the most
difficult aspect of life,
is to get really good at this moment.
Get really good at just existing in
the moment and enjoying with that.
It's fucking hard to do.
Right? Yup. It's great.
It's a great way of thinking about
it because it just means that, um,
you don't worry so much because you can,
you know,
there's stuff that you can
understand and relate to and, and be,
be good at and enjoy.
I think that's totally right and
there's some power and worry can't,
you can't worry about worrying
cause worry causes, preparation.
Preparation causes you to cover your
bases and remove a lot of paranoia because
you relax.
Like one of the best things you could
ever do if you're worried about something
as handle it, you know, you
handle it, you deal with it,
you don't have to worry about it anymore.
So I don't think there's anything
wrong with worrying a little bit,
but I think it's like all these
other things that we've discussed.
It's a balancing act. There's,
there's, uh, there's, uh,
don't go crazy and watch porn all day,
but if you watch a little bit,
I think you're going to
be okay. You know, don't,
don't get nutty and sit in
front of the TV 24 hours a day,
but watched game of
Thrones every now and then,
I don't think it's going to
hurt you. You know what, dude?
You get outside every now and then,
but don't stay there when it gets cold.
You need to get indoors. You
know, there's the world's big,
it's a lot of shit going on and it's
simply a matter of there's so much
happening and there's so much to take in
and there's so much going on that there,
there is not one good or bad.
There's just a bunch of different
things happening all at once. Yeah.
And that's why I totally agree with you
that the more you can give people the
freedom to experience and enjoy
and it's kind of, you know,
write their own story about how they,
how they do stuff and not be told what
to do by others, the better. Indeed.
CROWDPAC there you go.
Crowd pac.com.
That is the website if a,
if you're interested in that and the
elections are today and shockingly little
discussion both online and
on the news about them. Um,
but if your a,
if you're curious,
go to Crowdpac c r o d e p a c.com and uh,
and get your voting guide.
Get go there and click on it and
entering all the information and find out
what's going on. It's really,
I, I, I did check this out.
I think it's really pretty cool what
you've done, clinical priorities. It's,
you know, it's really early days. This
is the first little test version of it.
We just doing it for California.
So I'm sorry if people are
listening outside California,
we won't work so well for you.
I should say that this is a test,
but we'll be back for the
midterm elections in the
fall with them with a whole
new set of things and data for
politicians will have the country. Um,
so September we'll be
back with a much more, uh,
developed and a much sort of bigger and
better product and I think it's going to
really shake things up a bit. That's
the plan anyway. I think it will too.
I think it will too. And we need to get
you together with the young Turks. Yeah,
I've got some great,
I had checked that out after you mentioned
the wolf pack thing. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's on the right track when it
comes to that stuff too. Steve.
Thank you very much. But a lot of fun.
That was three hours, three hours,
three hours.
Just flew right back at that band.
He's a three o'clock thanks to our
sponsors. Thank you to a stamp,
scott.com go to stamps.com enter in the
code word j r e and get your $110 bonus
offer, which includes a digital
scale and up to $55 of free postage.
Thanks.
Also to legal zoom.
Go to legal zoom.com and use the code
word Rogan at check out for savings.
And thanks also to [inaudible],
go to [inaudible] dot ting.com and
save $25 off of any new device.
That's rogan.ting.com we will be back.
Uh,
this is it for the rest of the week.
We'll be back next week and a with a
lot of fascinating shit incent. Anyway,
we'll be here next Wednesday.
That's the next podcast. Until then,
go fuck yourself. No, don't do that.
Be Nice. Be Nice to each other.
Live in the moment. My friends
enjoy it. Much love big kiss.
Hm
hmm.